I get me all the time. I'm
more famous than them. I,
I wish we could tell you what
we were talking about. Uh,
and uh, yeah, we were talking about
Joey getting in trouble though.
He just texted me about it.
How's Joey Diaz get in trouble with what?
The MMA community MMA outlets.
They have nothing to do. Well,
here's the thing though.
I see where they're coming from.
They're journalists.
If someone says something that fucking
outrageous about what Mackenzie Durans
derriere must, uh, he said, I
think your ass smells great. Right?
Like something along those lines.
You're talking about the comic.
Uncle Joey said this, Joey, but I get it.
I get where they would and then
Vinny Magallanes backed him up.
I get it packed up Joey. Yeah,
backed up. Joey says tasty too.
Yikes. Yeah. Yikes. I get it. I
don't get it. That's a Joey Diaz,
the great comic who's commenting
on a hot girl in the UFC.
He is not a writer and he's
not a journalist. These
writers have nothing to do.
So they're like,
how can we get hits?
Let's talk about Joey Diaz cause
no one's reading any of our shit.
I agree with you somewhat,
but he definitely did do it.
Like it ain't a bat.
Here's my thing.
They could say whatever they
want about what he said,
but if he was your friend and he texted
you that you would do what I did cause
I'll show you. He fucking
texted me that before. Tweet.
Of course I love the Joey texts now.
Joey never would text message.
Oh I hope he doesn't keep your
ideas as a full on. Texted me.
He still calls though last week.
Most of the time he calls. But um,
he texted me. Uh, yeah,
it's Julie Diaz,
man.
Sorry folks. I wish I could let you
in. You can go Google what he said.
I'll try and be respectful.
It's Joey Diaz.
He can say whatever he wants. He doesn't
work for the UFC. He's not, he's not your,
you're right. I'm glad he does. I'm glad
he does think like that. How do you know,
send me texts like that.
But if I was a news website and it was
going to report out to, first of all,
you want to plates read. Yeah, went
cliff for sure. That's what they want,
but also anybody who
reads that are you really?
You're either going to be like me or
you're like you're going to start laughing
or you're going to get really upset,
really upset and you're not a Joey
Diaz fan anyway. It doesn't matter.
He's happy with that.
95% of that is dude's read and I'm like,
that's hilarious. The 5%
of like, what the hell?
What are we doing? How could you report
this? Yeah, I think that's a good number.
95 95% of duty. That's hilarious.
I was wondering the same thing.
Some women will get upset
though and rightly so if
just to imagine if you were a
dude and there were some big Ole giant
Alexander Corel and looking dude who
wanted to fuck you and he was always
making jokes about what your butthole must
smell like.
They just stop.
Just stop and think of what that would
feel like. That wouldn't be a good time.
If you're Mckenzie,
if you're anybody that someone is
saying those things about right,
I would just be just trying to be open
mind because you're not, you're being
a little bit turns social
justice. I'm fucking count. I
came out, I just, I'll feel,
but what I'm saying is if you look at
it from the position of the person,
the person who's buttholes in question,
that would be an uncomfortable
position to PN. Right?
Bunch of people talking about
what your butthole smelled like.
We just trying to make a living on TV.
I just tried to make a living.
Just tried to trick a girl.
He'll let that.
It's also Joey Diaz being complimentary.
It'd be one thing if she
was not an attractive female
or something like that and
she's obviously very attractive,
which is what makes this funny.
I agree 100% I agree.
Now if he tweets out,
I wonder what black beast asshole smells
like some like that to fully redeem
himself. That's funny too. I
don't know. He might. He might.
Yeah.
I don't know if he can get away with that.
You might just to throw it up there to
give those cheeto finger something to
write about. Joey's coming on with EOL
or Merrill. I cannot wait for that.
I cannot, it's going to be a complete,
that's the craziest podcast ever.
They're going to talk in in a Cuban
and I mean speak Spanish obviously.
Then go back and forth trends
go English and whatever.
Whatever he can't get Joey's going to
help him out with, you know, like if I'm,
if I talk too fast or if I say
something he doesn't understand,
Joey's going to jump in and they're going
to go away. It's going to be awesome.
It could be off. Some are complete shit.
You probably can be awesome. Yes. See,
be awesome with you and Joey. Joey's
just, he's a great entertainer.
I people don't understand like part of
the reason why he's so funny is he knows
what's in attaining for you Kirk.
He knows.
He knows how to be the life of the party.
Like no one counts.
Pretty God damn good at it too.
Calvin's up there.
Calcan entertainer room
count can take over Rome and,
and with some of the brings to the party.
I think that's his best art form.
I've told them that.
I think that your best art form is like
inappropriate comedy around people who
are trapped. Correct.
Stuck at a party. So Jay,
you're out of plane with them or
something and he can't go anywhere.
He's the funniest person I've,
he's made me laugh harder
offstage that almost sandy buddy.
It's so rude. He's right there. He's
right up there offstage with Joey.
But onstage, Joey's just, he's on
governmental, especially right now.
He's on another planet. All accounts
fucking hilarious on stage too.
But Joey right now, Jesus
Christ Callen just did his, uh,
like a showcase at the Improv.
How'd that go? You know,
and I've heard and murdered.
I kill.
That's good. I've been hearing
good things. That's good. Yeah.
That club is a not a,
not a bad club to work at now.
I wish they would get rid of that
stupid fucking piano on stage though.
That doesn't make any sense to me.
Piano was weird and Brian makes the same
joke about every time. It's hilarious.
Yeah. I won't say what it is. There's,
there's a part where you're standing,
especially if you go anywhere back on the
stage where the people that are on the
right side of the stage, like if you're
facing the audience, you're right.
Those people can't see you can't shame.
And there's not a lot of room either
is strange. It's stupid phrases.
Does anyone get on this fucking,
I dunno man.
We should have a carrot top or some shit.
Why? No Craig Robinson does on occasion.
Craig's own though. Yeah. Usually
has his electric piano. Denny,
maybe Owen Benjamin Ohn Benjamin can
play the fuck out of a piano lesson.
The moral of the story is
no one's really using that.
Even has a nick easy like huge penis was
like a website that he had or something.
Cause he's a giant dude. Uh, nobody's
using that fucking get rid of it.
Get rid of it. I want it. Doesn't need it.
Like most places don't need God
damn piano. That's so old school.
But just in the way it's an hindrance.
It's taking away from the show.
I really believe it
takes away from the show.
Can you name any other
club with a piano on stage?
Not Rarely. It's hard to think.
It's just a stupid thing to have,
but also look what the comedy store is
doing and then do the Robinson with his
own fucking keyboard. You're right. Yeah.
It usually comes out with his own shit.
Yeah. He's probably got a bunch of shit.
Oh sweater thing. Right? Look at him.
I bet he DZA GJS Dj's
the fuck out of a party.
He does look like a mean Dj. He does.
Right. You know who else Djs is? Shack.
If since shack like straight up DJ
his giant ass. Is it real Jay? Yeah,
that's what he does like in his office.
Got Platinum records, multiple p a DJ.
I was a rapper. No, that diesel CD went
platinum and he's got two I got to have,
I have one of them that's amazing returns.
I saw some video of him Dj and it's
like thousands of people like kids just
jamming out obviously high off their ass
on x e but it looked like a good time.
That's what he does. Why Not mad? Why not?
So Peter's is legit Dj legit legit friends
with all the old school rappers like
big Daddy Kane and shit.
I had no idea dude.
Russell is seriously legit.
Like when we had him on the
podcast a long time ago,
he actually look at the size of the shack
towering over that fucking equipment.
The biggest DJ in the world.
He's so big. He's so crazy. Um,
but Russell law doesn't like those other
guys calling themselves Dj's those like
ts doe guys. Really? Yeah, he says
that's not a DJ. He's like a DJ.
Someone who knows how to play records.
These guys are like pressing play on their
laptop and bouncing around with their
hands up in the air.
I mean,
I think there's more to apply agree kind
of just hitting the playlist and doing
your thing. I think there's more
to that. It's a different thing.
But to those people that want to hear
that different, those are the masters.
It's like,
I just think it's silly to get hung up
on one art form or another cause in any
art form you're going to have.
There's Russell tearing it up.
See now he actually knows how to
like and scratch and all that shit.
He's a talented dude is smart dude.
What else is a very experienced, smart,
very good dude too. Like one of the
nicest people I've ever met. Super,
super fucking sweetheart. First we had a
roast me on stage. It hurt my feelings,
but then that was the way of just kind of
all bus a little bus than to the
balls. He's just, I love him. Yeah,
he's a sweetheart.
But um,
he's like super passionate about old
school DJ in like with record players and
shit. Like he's really good at that.
And there's an, there's an art to that,
but that's why he hates on these
new guys. Like Dj ts, stow and well,
he doesn't hate on them.
He doesn't hate on them.
He just doesn't think that they should
call themselves djs. Dj a disc jockey,
you know what I'm saying?
Anyway, each disc jockey
though, but they're not a disc.
They don't have a disc. He's got
a disc and that's part of his art.
He's moving disc. Leslie's
disc jockey. I see it.
Point is like,
I just think people let people love
that kind of music obviously like Calvin
Harris Shit.
Hell yeah.
And I'm not saying shit in a bad
racist jams a way of describing it.
But as you're driving down
the road in Vegas, man,
she's big ass Calvin era's
posters and shit and yeah, Diplo,
all those electronic guys.
I mean obviously people love that sound
so I don't think he's saying that they
suck. I just think he's saying it's
a different thing. Different. Yeah.
Cause like obviously if you wanted to
hear that shit and you got went there and
Russell was scratching records,
she'd be like, come on, come on Bro.
I'm here to do ecstasy and listen to do
dat, Dat, Dat, Dat, you
know, you know, disc jockey,
a person who introduces in
plays recorded popular music,
especially on radio or at a discount.
They're electric Dj.
Maybe time to update that fucking
super old school. What the fuck is it?
Disco had a disco disco.
How about a ballroom?
The thing about those Djs like Steve
Aoki at a documentary on Netflix,
which is ridiculous, but because
they're not like live performing,
they can do more shows than anyone.
So like Steve Aoki was on the road 300
days out of the year, made something like,
oh my God,
300 gagillion dollars private jet.
He's going from Amsterdam to
China. Yeah, just nonstop. Yeah.
That's all he do. He was at the
Onnit lab. It all out there.
He was the guy who is stolen cakes
and people's faces, mainly girls.
He'd toss cake there.
That was his thing.
And then kit one girl and her neck
was a kid. I think he had a lawsuit,
so he stopped throwing the cake and
they're very, I don't throw cakes.
It was awesome. People would ask for
it though. This is what he would do
both. Is that the girl that
got hurt? No. I don't know.
Some girl got whiplash though.
Throw
a cake.
Oh my God.
With like a piece of cardboard underneath
it is that it's just the bottom of the
cake.
You know what I'm saying?
You gotta put on something that seems
sult longest cake toe hits guy in a
wheelchair. Well, that's not,
oh, let's not watch this.
I don't want to watch the guy in
the wheelchair get hit in the head.
He's all yet. Oh my God.
Maybe it's an honor, right?
Maybe if you're a fan of Steve Aoki,
it's like hit me with the cake. Right?
Like if you're like,
I had to WWE and someone spits on you,
there's a little bit of blood
or something and it did.
They catch that conversation spit or
in the NBA that when they fill their
mouthpiece, people catch
them. It's disgusting.
Heaven's MMA to you can do with
that thing. I've seen that. Yeah.
Why do people throw them in the
audience? Right. I don't know.
It's so does seem so preposterous.
What does this, Jamie, what is it?
You said blood spitting blood. This is
it. The guy left and at the Arnold thing,
doctors started spraying and blood
right in the middle of his lift. Whoa.
That's where all clean up everything.
I'd take a little break.
You need to see a doctor. Sure. He's fine.
Got a little stomach thing
going on. That's internal
bleeding. He's got a little,
uh, Nan's probably nasal infection.
You think bursting. I like that.
Walk it off. You can't be good. I
just dead lift a thousand pounds.
Looks pretty healthy to me. Let me see.
Deadlifts and live a long time. Nine 39.
It says she sees this crisis
[inaudible] so much weight.
I saw crazy one where a dude
was doing the squat and the,
the bar couldn't handle the weight and
the bar bet and he couldn't get it back
onto the rack. And so he had to
like kind of dive out from under it,
but it was a shitload of weight.
Obviously.
Imagine that with that kind of weight
on you and you got to figure out how to
get it off you.
So without it hurting you.
Have you seen homeboy who when they do
the heavy squats and they blow their
asshole out? Oh, I did see that.
That's a tough one. Yeah. I would say,
I would thought you were going to
bring up that guy who was doing, um,
who's doing something,
one of those crossfit games and he was
doing like a clean and his arms gave out
and it dropped down in his
neck and paralyzed him.
Damn Nah, keep it positives.
A friend at Tate's
landed on his neck out,
dead,
just fell down.
It stops being realized now he's paralyzed
from the neck down. She just boom,
like everything just shut off.
He landed on his neck,
probably pass on the crossfit for, well,
you know what it's on. These guys are two,
almost two fucking tough for their own
good with something like that where
you're holding something over your head.
Do you want a thousand reps or just
they're just trying to smash everybody's
reps and Charlotte how bad ass they are,
which is, you know, it's competition.
[inaudible] hates that shit. He says that
and I see other peoples points to that.
It's beneficial that the
competition makes you work harder,
but Maxwell's take on it is those type
of exercise movements like power cleans
and things like that, they're not clean
up. It's not meant for high reps. I know.
Yeah. Those are a strength moves.
They're meant for low reps,
couple sets, you know, heavy shares.
That's not something your body,
you shouldn't be doing that and the things
that can go wrong and gonna fuck you
up.
Especially when you start going tons and
you're losing your technique and form.
It's dangerous shit man. You lose. And
this guy was out of position too. I mean,
just as bodies. July's tastes.
Boy, he had, Tate knows him.
Tate Tate's big in that.
He's a deepen that crossfit world.
He has a lot of those classes.
Finished. Barbell clever.
What's his thing over there?
He just something off Lincoln
in Venice. He's always,
he's always there. They just liked some
strong man shit. There's kids everywhere.
I know you're talking about the name
escapes me and me to the box. No,
I sign it. The box and
Venice. Hell, whatever.
Calworks works at Venice barbell club
Tate's always been into hate somewhere
counts though. That kind of working out to
sit back in the day. Is it Doosan? Yeah.
Okay. There you go. Shout out to
do Suzanne. What's up dude? Yeah,
Tate's always been into cattle bells and
you know, muscle ups and shit like that.
And it's just crossfit style movements.
And he's a big fan of crossfit.
He loves it. Have you done
a, a ton of a crossfit? No.
I mean I've done, I do those
kind of exercises, right?
I do a lot of a kettlebell stuff.
I do dead lifts.
I do a lot of things to do training,
but not,
but I don't do it the way they do
it now. Maybe I do that. Pavel,
Tat Salini method where you're
doing like sets of five,
never more than sets of five.
I take that and I take a lot of
time off in between sets. I uh,
I schedule's been so crazy,
man.
I haven't been able to go to the gym like
it typically do you know where I work
with my trainer and not doing weights?
I'll do mid stuff like that.
So I've been trying to find
some alternatives. Yeah, man,
it's fun to make shit up.
Something different. Yeah. I've
been board like a yoga class,
take up and doing yoga, doing hot yoga,
which I love talking tae kwan doe, Bro.
How about that? You want to go
deep? Double Knife Ham along me.
Go deep after post career
front kick and motherfuckers I,
I'll pop a hard pass on that man.
I don't want anything to do with Marshall,
but here's the thing. It's
like, do you like, uh,
some sort of muck dojo style taekwondo
song as they teach you good technique.
You're going to get a good workout and
try and burn some calories. You know,
you could work at it.
I'm sure.
I'm sure we'll kicks and
shit hard pass hard pass.
Joe Ito just for a goof.
Just you and the fit with the pajamas.
Just wrist lock and motherfucker
slipping them grabbing that risk.
You fly, fly, fly in on
the ground. Steven Seagal.
That'd be sick. Ooh. Ah, the risks mix.
I go full deep on that. No, would
be fine if you did it and you just,
you did one of them. Uh,
I kido demonstrations.
You show what happens when someone doesn't
just give in. Do you see? He'd be like,
he goes and grabs you and does this and
you're like, push him away from you.
They try to throw you and you just
kind of pushed her head down. I like,
come on man, come on man. Come on
Bro. You don't try to counter them.
You just go cut. Just cut shots.
Just kept this cause this shake, not,
not working.
You have to like throw yourself at them.
It's all bullshit.
But apparently man, those dudes who
were bad ass I did back in the day,
it was about getting rid of swords.
Guy Comes at you with a
fucking sore and they're all,
they had to learn how to like the
guy's lunging at you literally with a
ridiculous movement cause he's
trying to just chop you up. Right.
So it would be similar to how these
guys move and throw those yeah.
And those demonstration videos.
But that shit is not negotiable.
If a guy doesn't have a sore, so old
school too, it's just fucking wait.
Well I was thinking about doing this
isn't a sponsor, anything like that.
I was looking at those because
you have one in the back there.
One of those penalty.
What? Pelton bikes. Yeah.
So you work at Pella and just wake
up and do that and then do my thing.
Those are great.
I think they have a whole thing.
You'd do a bunch of different workouts
and go online like online cloud.
This is a spot. You do it live too.
But you know what I like better.
I like the rogue bike. That fucking
assault bike. What is it called? The Echo.
The airdyne. Yeah. Jesus Christ. They
made a beefed up version of what?
I have one here. Yeah, I see two bottles
on it. 20 seconds on, 10 seconds off.
Holy Shit Dude. If I give the Pendleton
bike, that rogue thing and uh,
and uh, or the aerodynamic, like
a rower, I'd be straight. Yeah.
Rowers bad. I got a row or two rowers. Bad
Ass too. I do 30 and 30 with the rower.
So 30 minutes of sprint
in 30 minutes arrest,
30 minutes of sprint in 30 minutes
seconds. She's just Christ.
Are you on, sir? Imagine if
you could just sprint for 30
excuse me,
30 seconds.
So the Tabata is a 2010
and then I go from,
I do like um,
it'll do eight rounds of 2010 and then I
go over and do the row machine and I'll
do eight rounds of 30 30 30 seconds on,
30 seconds off.
And then I'd go back and do it
again and then I'd do it again.
And if I've got the sauce, if I got the
stones, I could do three sets. Austin,
I've only done three sets once and I
had a double up on the shroom tech.
You felt sick. I was beat
down, man, you're just really
exhausted at the end of it.
It's also a short and your body.
Super intense at the tongue they sit and
most people think that's the best word
that you can do. It does
something to you, I guarantee you.
Because one of things after doing
it like three or four times,
I started to feel it in my running.
It called running a lot too though.
But my running,
my endurance and runnings getting better.
And I think maybe some of that
might have to do with the biking.
Just cause the buzzer.
Mike works out different muscles to men.
Your lungs too when it has to adapt to
that kind of capacity moving like that.
That's not it. It's the beefy one. I
will break that shit. Just saw it Jamie.
It's called the rogue echo.
Echo air or some shit.
I've been doing a the thousand meter
test on the row, like I'll get done,
hit mitts on my train and then
they go 8,000 meters. I see.
They have the records for the week.
I try and beat the records and just so
anybody knows, that's not a sneaky ad.
I paid for all the rogue stuff. It's here.
I bought it all. No, no, that's it. Right.
That dog thing is beefy, beefy
as fuck. Got Girders and shit.
You got a fat ass handle on a girder.
Yanni.
Step my game up so I don't have
to leave to the gym to save time.
It's nice to be able to just
do it in your house. You know,
all you need is a chin up bar and
some kettle bells at home and,
and you could just get something done.
That's what I need because sometimes you
know that thing where you have really,
you have an hour before you have to leave.
Like a might be looking to the gym
and squeeze 30 minutes in. That's the,
that's what I've been doing.
Yeah.
It's cause I have to wake up with my son
and I'm like done with him and then him
with an hour and then you'd
be at the studio here.
I'm going to New York and doing this. I
just wanted to do something at home. Dude.
I become addicted to the fasted cardio.
I used to do that before.
[inaudible] are thrown up. Yeah, but I
think that's your coffee intake. Yeah.
You're probably ready to talk.
What do you like 20 cups a day or
something under 16 cuffs and then fasting
until to the doctors,
not tooth, that moron.
That's so much. Whatever. It's so much.
Just too much of the switch of everything
and if you not having any food then
it's just going straight in there.
It's all getting absorbed.
I'm on all these medications now.
I had to get off Kido real dying.
Joe Have Stage one diabetes.
What is the medications?
They put up some antiacid
like super strong stuff so
I can still drink my coffee.
It's just not a possibility. It's not to
keep my coffee. I have to. I was like,
you will. You will fuck
up my entire workflow if I
can't drink coffee. So crazy.
Yeah, but fasting cardio is the
way to go. Yeah. I love it, man.
I get addicted to it.
You know when I get addicted to,
I get addicted to the feeling of having
done it when I didn't want to do it.
That's what I realized. This
running thing is for me. It's this,
this little game I'm playing with my
brain where I know I'm going to do it,
but I wake up, I'm like, oh,
and then Marshall's Barkan
I'll put him in the backyard. It's like,
come on bitch. He wants to go. Dude,
he's so crazy now.
I love that we've been doing it so much
so he's in really good shape at fucking
dogs and shaped dogs. Getting shaped
like that. He's getting a little Chubby,
you know, but he was the only like
you still had baby fat on him.
He's only 14 months old.
So when I took him he was like nine or
10 months old when I first started taking
them.
I just wasn't sure if he was going to
listen or I was worried like what if we
run into a rattlesnake or something
like that would suck. It sucks.
He got used to the routine.
You could get them to the hospital though.
They survived. They're a lot tougher
than us, you know, suck it out.
Switch to hit him on the nose. You
get us knock it out. That's not real.
That's what I've heard bro.
I've heard it too. It was ready.
So fake that just bro Science, it doesn't
work but it can really suck it out.
Dogs die cause it hits him on the
nose and so you know it gets spread.
That's what I've heard. No, my
dog had been on the nose. Use.
Your dog has my pit by ral sake. Yeah.
Did he die? No, he's still alive now.
He's dead now. Was a long time ago
when we doing this a long time ago.
I all my dogs got bit by rattlesnakes
except [inaudible] squeaky Fromme she was,
uh, she didn't give a fuck about snakes.
She was just fuck up other dogs did her,
that was my prison dog.
That was a dog that I got from the
pound that was in the power of this from
Callan count and count suggestion
feel quite yet what is in the city,
the La animal shelter for like
five or six months. It was a sweet,
sweet dog doe people.
It did not want any dogs ruining
her new found party dog aggression.
Well she,
she lived for the formative months
of her childhood before I got her,
she lived in his cage and I think
that that fucks with a dog's head.
Nobody adopted her for like, I think
it was at least five or six months.
Poor bunny.
And then once you finally do get adopted
and get all this love for these people,
you get to sleep in bed with them
and shit and they take you home.
And I mean a dog was,
she slept right by my bed.
Sometimes they would hop in the bed,
but I have to kick them off
because they fart and shit. See,
I like him in the bed. I like to
the dogs in the bed. Keep it. Yeah,
it does keep it warm, but sometimes they
fart and it's brutal. You like, oh Jesus,
if it's a hot summer nights, I get outta
here. Man. I know the itchy and shit.
But um, she so like any dog that she
thought might steal that from her,
like any dog that came in, she just,
she would growl with dogs. You pet them.
She just was not into it.
So insecurity issues.
There's good and bad guys are running
all the time. I've never, I've,
I struggled with that a little bit
lately where I'll be tired and I'm like,
come on, you got to work out. I've never
had a work out. And then afterwards went,
man, I wish I didn't do
that. Yeah, well, ever.
Not once people are saying this
to people need to understand,
like I saw a couple of comments people
saying this is terrible advice and you
should listen to your body when
your body is tired. The snapshot.
That's not right. No, you're
not. No, no tired. Yeah,
I know what I need to rest and I also can,
I know like how when I've done too much
stuff, like I've done like two works out,
two workouts a day,
three days in a row before and then you
get to that fourth day and you're like,
Whoa, all right. I probably should
do nothing today. Like just that's,
that's almost tougher to do them
working out for me to take a day off.
It's almost tougher psychological. Yes.
Cause I'm like, oh don't be a pussy.
You don't see him right
now. He's going good. Right?
You body starts thinking it's going to go,
but there's a moment where you
realize that you're probably,
I should really monitor my
resting heart rate in the morning.
That's another thing
Steve Maxwell taught me.
He said that that's one of the best ways
to figure out if you're overtraining,
we're training.
We still do wake up in the morning.
If your heart rate is five to 10
beats over, what it normally is,
don't do shit because you're
fighting something off.
Either you're fighting something off
where you need to recover and you can do
like light skill work.
They say if you're sick,
working out makes it worse because
it messes up your immune system,
your immune system. You're usually,
I know if I'm being lazy, I'm like,
God was trying to rest in bed, man. Oh, I
just want to do this. I'd rather do this,
but you know what? If you're not too sick,
if you're not too debilitated to work,
it's not, it's not a bad thing to just
do light, no focus work. Just move.
Like try to figure out some technique
where you're not doing anything hard in
the steam room or sauna. Sauna. Yeah,
and someone who asks me
about steam versus Sauna.
I as Rhonda Patrick and there's,
there hasn't really been studies done on
the sauna or the steam room either that
show the benefits of the sauna, but it'll
probably ship that both how to shit.
It probably has some benefit.
The only difference is that the sauna can
get way hotter because it's a dry heat
so the sonic can get, you know, my son,
I've had it up to more than 190 we sucked
up and headed to send that Sutton in
Boston. You're a serial killer. The
10 more minutes shop and I was dying.
I was like, ah, I think I'm
set, man. Think I'm kind of set.
I'm all red like a lobster.
It's just got to go.
You just gotta just go empty in there.
I know, I hear Ya. But I was good man.
Like no, we were in there for a
minute. Jamie dipped out super early.
10 minutes before everybody.
I didn't know that. Hey,
Jamie got their first shout out to
equinox and Boston. Great fucking gym.
That's a good night, man. Yeah,
they keep it at one 70 that's what
most people think it should be.
One 70 but if she was one
seven he would steam. Man,
you're getting cooked in there.
That's not good.
I don't think you can take that heat,
so the idea is that the sauna,
because it's a dry heat for the most part,
I know sometimes people throw
some water on the rocks,
but it's a dry heat for the most part,
and that that is what you want because
that's what your body responds to,
the just the actual temperature and
producers, those heat shock proteins.
That makes sense. Totally makes sense.
You know, it's weird sometimes in the UFC,
and you can feel this too,
if it's at a hockey arena,
like t mobile where the sometimes the,
when you get into the octagon again,
that crowd,
it's freezing because there's ice
on the low fee for the fighter.
Yeah. It takes a while
to get going. You see?
You'll see guys for the first round like,
God,
he looks a little stiff or what's going
on here? It's freezing out there, man.
You're Justin shorts,
right?
You're sweating in the back and
it's warm in that locker room.
Then when you come out,
it's this God,
so he's a total difference when you
get in right away. I'd like, goddammit.
I'd always think about it. Is that
a hockey team there? Oh there's ice.
So I had to calculate that thought
or focus on something else,
but I didn't realize it until one day I
saw like a crack in between the boards,
the floorboards and I looked
down, I went, that's fucking ice.
There's ice there right now. And like you
get to keep it. They keep the ice there.
They keep ice,
they keep ice.
You're just all these thousands
of people chill on top of ice.
Well it can't break. No, I'm just
saying it's kind of weird. Oh,
it's definitely weird. But it's it better.
Well not for the fighters for sure.
But is it better for the audit?
Because it,
sometimes it gets fucking hot in those
places if you have a just a big ass chunk
of ice in the middle of everybody.
I think keep kind of smart.
Like the only time it's been
super cookie is in, in Brazil.
There's didn't use any AC or anything.
I was in one of them and it was
an open air place in Brazil,
so we're indoors but at the top,
the top areas,
it's like these big open doors that face
the outside. There's bugs flying around.
Shit. Some Brazilians shit man. It
was moist and warm. Where was though?
It was Wa there's one with Anik in someone
and they're literally just sweating
the pit stains and sweating it out.
That happened in Abu Dhabi too.
We're not with Dobie. I was drenched.
That was outdoors. That was an outdoor,
yeah. Who was that mean? Hilson Weidman
Anderson. Damien Maia. That's right.
Yeah. Why did we find out there
too? I forget. I think you flat.
Bj Penn fought Frankie Edgar.
That's where a Frankie Edgar won
the title and the, they've had Roy.
Yeah. Nog out there. Yup. Haven't been
back there in a while. It's been a while.
It's been a minute. Hot Minute.
Yeah. That one was crazy cause you,
you saw bugs flying around and you never
knew were real [inaudible] shit out
there. I went on a hike. I was like,
oh I'm in Jumanji. This is cool. Like,
what in the fuck is this shit you've
never seen before? It's crazy.
He'd go to other countries,
man, they're there.
They have completely different ecosystems.
The point where you look at things,
you go, what in the fuck is that? What
is that? But where it's dangerous too.
I remember I was in Brazil,
we are climbing this thing and they go,
now listen fellas, you got to
make sure we're with the locals.
Like you have to come
down before nightfall,
otherwise they're not going to find you.
What kind of Shit is this?
So we just dipped out getting up there
and my man, I man, her legs like, man,
you got lost. He, we didn't see him for
the rest of the night. The local was like,
he's one, he's one with the
jungle now. I'm like, Whoa,
what the fuck does that mean?
The rundown and some shit.
What do you mean he's one with the jungle?
He just,
he said he showed up a day later, just
exhausted. Don't get an ounce of sleep.
And someone in one of these huts took
them under their wing and saved them.
Oh my God. People up. Do you
get helicoptered out of there?
If they get trapped at
the top? I was like, dude,
I feel like I shouldn't be doing fight.
I feel like it's a bad idea.
How many days before a fight was this?
This was like a week before. It's crazy.
The guy in front of us had assumed gone
basically a speedo just asshole out in
front of us.
Just fucking going and I'm like
[inaudible] your foot and just doing work.
Smoking US shredded 10 fucking
all us with their feet look like,
like hobbits feed like
fucking craziest feed ever.
These people that live in the forest,
they splay out like a hand and they,
they're super thick toes and she didn't
like it doesn't look anything like, no,
we have bitch feet. Yeah Dude.
Believe me man. Sore today.
I had a run in regular running shoes
because my feet are sore from the vibrams
and yeah, from the just
the pounding. I know.
I'm scared of that plantar fasciitis than
we ever had it. No, get your mind right.
Let's go ahead and get on.
There's a reason there's technology son.
Let's quit run beer. But no, no, no.
I think it just the barefoot
thing strengthens your feet up.
I think it just takes time. I'm just
being real careful. Be Super careful.
It's a nightmare. I'm sure
Dominick Cruz had to deal with it.
I've done it at night.
I had to get shots and Jackson and my
foot and with dom cruisey was the same
thing. It was coming back too quickly.
Like he, he had a knee injury, right.
So after his knee injury then he
just tried to get way back in shape,
way quick and
fucked his feet up.
Mine was just,
I think from being so big in this
running I was doing, you know,
miles and miles and miles and
miles. I love running. It's layered.
My favorite thing to do,
Neil Brennan did it on it.
He got planner from a treadmill from
wearing those vibrams. If, if you're,
they say you got to work
into them kind of work.
Just don't want it to go straight
barefoot and just start doing work. No,
you definitely do. To me,
you do good to be barefoot.
Like I like walking in the street.
I feel like I'm doing something dangerous.
Like on the sidewalk. Korea flit.
Yeah, like double. I'm while go. Wow.
I feel nice about it. I don't know what
it is, man. It makes me feel free. Yeah,
I know. It's dirty and dangerous
clothes to get dirty and dangerous.
That's what life is supposed to
be supposed to be. Interacting,
interacting with other life barriers.
That's your feet.
Nice rubber barrier between you and
the world. That shit ain't right.
You always can find. I like to let
them breathe a little bit. Man.
One of the Indians had it
right with moccasins. He,
there's no airflow with
those Goddamn moccasins.
They didn't give a fuck with
things smelled like back then.
All that smelled like they gave up. They
just didn't give a fuck. That felt like
if they could find a creek, the temporary,
put some of that fire out real quick.
I'm not about that life. I'm
not, I'm not like that ma'am,
but they would just run
around with moccasins.
They basically just had like a layer of
leather between their foot in the ground.
It's all they could do. Climb
mountains with that. Hey,
hey, hey, what is this Jamie?
How dare you Jamie? This guy is slicing
chunks off of the bottom of his foot.
I mean those houses that
makes me feel sick, bro.
Man cuts cows off his foot
with a knife and dog eats it.
This is the name of this video.
How the fuck did you find that?
Look at these callouses,
dude, this is insane, bro.
This guy is just slicing through
these cows is like, it's a coconut,
like it's coconut milk. It's
like a pineapple. This is insane.
Have you ever seen anybody have cows?
It's like this before though.
I think this guy has a problem.
Why ain't normal?
What kind of a man can just
cut out his foot like that?
How do you don't hop how deep to cut?
We don't cut your him he off.
You know this dude is not sharpening
that knife. That's not a sharp knife.
That's not she's, this is crazy ma.
That guys can feed them and the dog,
the dog is taking the pieces of
meat mean a dog's a man eater.
That's how in the world foreign TV,
Jamie's got that bookmarked.
Couldn't wait. Did you say feet?
Just couldn't wait till the track.
That shit.
Who the fuck cuts off the bottom of their
feet with a knife like that and what's
he doing to get his feet like that?
Why is he yelling at that
dog while I taught his feet?
That makes it this close thrown out.
Wouldn't you like to think that the dog
would get used to that smell like that's
what I like to eat now and then like
you'll be sleeping. The dog's hungry.
He's like, fuck it. I'm just kind of snack
out in this dude's feet. Zombie. Doug,
you got a Zombie dog in his now it
looks like a bloodhound to dogs.
Got Damn horrible monster
meeting either human neater.
Wow. Going to feel super sick man.
On another note, how about that?
Brian Ortega, the other know
how bout banner take, give him,
I don't want to show yesterday night
as awkward cause me and Brian are super
close and I don't know what it is
because same thing with Steve Bay.
Whenever I know these guys,
it's a, I know him from when,
when I trained with them and I've seen
it in that light like with Brian or take
a corner him for his,
one of his fights before he got to the
UFC and I knew him as that Brian or Tayga
where all Jujitsu, you know, cardio
for days, but terrified to fight.
Like I know miss is that Brian and now
he's evolved into the number one feather
weight in the world. So when I, when he
get the Frankie Edgar fight, I was like,
God, I just feel like it's
a terrible match up man. I'm
telling Hannah, I'm like,
what's he going to do? And he's
like, don't worry man, don't worry.
And so on my show,
which Brian and Heather listen to,
to like do they come in and like, how are
you gonna pick against me? I'm like, no.
I said, my brain went with
frank. You just, cause it's
Frankie Edgar, he's a legend.
My heart wanted to do Brian.
He's like, dude, it hurt my
feelings. I'm like, I don't,
I don't, I'm sorry man. Like I, and I
don't know what it is with Steve Bay too.
Whenever I see him,
I know him as that version of them.
It's a problem that I have. I like
this gap. I don't know what's going on.
People always do that.
They do that.
You remember someone by what they were
when they were at their worst and not
even the worst, but it's in the infancy
of their, of their, of their careers,
their worst. Just say a lesser version
of who they are now. Correct. Right.
It's like, do you ever get that feeling
when you go back to high school?
Like if I'm around someone from
high school, I feel like a loser.
I know this is a weird feeling, not
100% when I go back to Denver, I'm,
I'm almost not myself because I feel
like this almost the Allen was like this
loser. A loser because, yeah,
because you remember back who you were
when you were insecure and starting out
in life and just that's a normal thing.
You know,
they always say that about comedy clubs.
Like if you start out at a club,
that club will never respect you. They
respect you when you leave and you know,
maybe you get a TV show or something
like that and then come back and the gay.
Yeah, I remember when you sucked
though. Do you remember when you suck?
I always had it. I had a problem with
that and Boston at first. Really? Yeah,
because they remembered me as this guy
who was an opener and then you know,
how am I had like I remember when you
were opening and you did 20 minutes,
you open. That's what you do. I
know. Like you're not a headliner.
I had one night and this is not in my
nature at all. I'm going to go back.
It just been busy. But I had one
at the laugh factory. I've just,
I bombed Ben Bom Bom like, like, cause
like I should probably not do this.
Oh, just one guy in
the back. She goes, oh.
I'm like, no doubt. No doubt man. I
get in the car and I drive down sunset.
I'm like, what the fuck am I
doing man? It's so embarrassing.
I've been back since but not
because because of my column scare,
the laugh factory.
It's just that I've been at the store
and then just been on the grind,
but I do have it in your head like you
got to get back up there and clean that
up and literally I think about every
day it's something back here and to get
your ass up there, man. We go, but
I'll go to the comedy store. Nope,
get your ass up there. See
that's an athlete's perspective.
That's the difference.
It's one of the things that I've
been saying to people about you.
The difference between way
you've been approaching
comedy and another person would do it.
You're doing it from an
athlete's perspective.
Like you work hard at Shit and you know
where your weaknesses are and you got to,
you fix those other people,
ignore him. That's a real problem.
You know like it.
Like someone will have a joke and the
joke doesn't do well like several nights
in a row, but they keep
doing it the same way. Like,
why are you doing it the same way?
You need to cut some of that out.
You need to tweak this and you turn
that around and needed to add something.
Maybe not explaining it enough,
but if it's not doing well and you
keep doing it the same exact way,
it's not the crowds Homan. Yeah, you got
to figure out they're there to laugh.
People get stuck in a weird pattern
though of wanting to do things exact same
way over and over again. Oh,
nothing's better than me when it,
it's such an honor to have him
at the comedy store. If I was,
it comes through in La Jolla in a
comic go, hey, you should try this.
I listen to jokey. Should button with
this or try this. I'm like, dude,
that's brilliant, man. Yeah. Every now and
then someone will just nail it for you.
They just find, they see something
that maybe you didn't see any like, oh,
like you ever thought about going
this direction? I'm like, dude,
it's not like the writing your jokes like,
Hey,
what if we went this direction with,
I'm like that dude. That's brilliant.
Man That's happens in martial arts too,
right?
Like hasn't someone like pointed something
out to and you're like, oh shit. Oh,
100% with a choker. Your hands are like
this. Do you ever tried it like this?
And I do that. Yeah. That makes
sense. It's so much easier. Yeah.
Sometimes things don't seem like they'd
be easier and they are like this,
that Pretzel Grip, this
grip. And you're like,
why would I grab something like that?
And then you do and you like,
if someone shows you, but I
feel like not in my, yeah,
it feels nice. Feels Nice. Oh you ain't
getting, no, no, no. It's a bribe.
Or take your shit to his guillotine
is ridiculous and icy grip it and he's
getting, he, he's, he's just a,
he has all sorts of variations.
Emma fuckers Nice with it.
He's here, you know it's right.
You know he's here a lot of times
he goes flat. He's so good at it.
But cozy like Marcello, like
how Marcel slides it. Yeah.
Like a blade catches laid.
Yeah. And he's, he's the best
at the world in it. But he also,
he's getting the respect now from the
crowd because if you remember when Frankie
kind of fake that shot and got ahold of
his neck then craton tire cargoes. Yeah.
Cause it's like,
oh shit.
They realize what he's capable of when
that dude gets a hold of your neck.
It's a totally different proposition.
When he would,
he did to cub Swanson at
the end of the first round,
basically be that cob basically out cub
was fucked and it was just a matter of
the time ran out.
But that shit was fully locked
in and cub wasn't going anywhere.
I got emotional yesterday when he came
in the room because I haven't seen him
since and I went [inaudible] not even
on air went, hold on. Stop though Bro.
Let hear me real quick before we went.
Tells you this under you get
in touch all that and went,
you're the number one
feather weight in the world.
Remember I cornered you for
that rough and nasty fighting.
Would her Glendale where
the fuck with or that? No,
he's the number one guy in the world.
Brian let that soak in.
He's a number one contender.
Max Holloway's in number one in the world.
He's ranked number one the world.
Right, but number one contender true.
He's number one. I was insane.
That's always the champ.
That's the number one until they find the
champion. Right. Number one the world.
That was the message.
I not understand that.
That if I was Max
Holloway motherfucker for,
well they're going to fight for sure.
Not Max Holloway is the greatest
featherweight in the world right now,
but for providing or Tayga to
go from. It's crazy to see, man.
It's a very interesting fight.
It's nuts cause the Ortega is super
dangerous standing in on the ground.
He's on a totally different level than
anybody else. They're also the same size,
like the way it usually has a
big advantage of reach and size,
but now they're kind of equal. Dude.
Holloway something special though, man.
He's something special.
Special. He did it.
Although when he did the Aldo was
crazy twice, twice and the second time.
More emphatic like,
like he knew he was getting no,
that's always something special.
Special.
And it's almost like when
you watch what he does,
you can't appreciate it until
you see it a bunch of times.
Because like what he's doing, he's not
knocking someone out with one head kick.
He's not like catching someone with some
unbelievable spectacular submission.
No. What he's doing is just fucking you
a cause. Outclassing regularly. Yeah,
with technique and he's ferocious.
And then where do you want to do you want
to do take out, do you want to do pace?
You want a little bra? You want a bra?
I'm gonna draw the line right here.
Come ball and see how that goes for it.
And that's what Brian kept fall into.
And I, Brian will be, I'm sure in Vegas
eyes, the underdog, which rightfully so,
it's Max Holloway, the greatest
featherweight in the world right now.
So with Brian Hitch says to be careful,
Max alert you into that brawl and he's
not going to lose those brawls. Yeah,
he's very good at Bra and that's
for damn sure. And he did.
The crazy thing was the, the lamas
fight. Oh my God. Ricardo Lamas.
He's beating his ass and then he
just points the set of the schedules.
Come on man, let's fucking throw it
out. He's one of my favorite fighters.
Then bites his mouthpiece down. It's
just windmill and that you can do that.
Can you do technique? You want to
do Jitsu? Whatever you want to do.
I really want to do. It sounds like
from what Brian told me is they're,
they're aiming for that international
fight week. So you'd have DC, Steve Bay,
maybe Cyborg, Amanda Nunez. Then you
got Brian. We're taking Max Holloway.
Well matches broke his foot.
So what are we at right now?
How many weeks is he out?
Is even out of his cast yet.
I don't think he's out of his cast.
I think I saw a photo of him on
Instagram was about two weeks ago.
He had a cast on,
he's on tough help in DC right though.
You probably done the tough catches or
doing it, you know, standing on his cast.
But who are we in March, April,
May, June, April, May, June, July,
four months. Um, a foot of
bone in the foot is not,
it's not an easy one because
you're always standing on it. No.
And then when you get back,
it's going to take time and then you're
going to be real hesitant to kick things.
Well, Hey, I, I'm not the one who started
the rumor was international fight week.
That's what, yeah, that's what,
that's what, or take his hearing. He,
they want to do in Hawaii. Obviously
Heather and Brian wanted, they were like,
we'd love to go to Hawaii, go to his
hometown and do it. But you know,
there's a lot of moving
pieces for UFC get to Hawaii.
Well the other thing is
inside and outside, like how,
how big of an arena
they have that's inside.
It was well outside the of the stadium,
right?
They could do the giant state in which
would sell out. It would sell out.
But what if it rained,
which it does in Hawaii all the time.
We fighting in the ring wet and wild.
Remember that one and watch that.
Can you the cage, you wouldn't
watch that rainy, the rainy. I mean,
it'd be so weird, but no, you can't
take the breast to have. Yeah,
it's a good risk to have.
Look, can't have it though.
You got to be phenomenal for Brian.
If they could just slip to the ground
real quick. Amazing for he has,
he has a good advantage over
almost everybody at one 45
when it comes to Jujitsu,
like who doesn't have an advantage of when
it comes to Jujitsu at one 45? No one,
no one more dangerous than t city swabs
on the ground and he locks on to things.
There's a finale to it, that strength in
his, now his belief in himself with it,
he knows how dangerous he is. There's a
it and really it's, he's almost, you know,
people haven't seen what that
kid's capable of either. Like we,
we seen some cool stuff,
but some of his flying triangle is
flying armbars in his, his, his,
his grips and stuff and
his guillotines and his,
a lot of cool setups that we haven't
even touched on. So, yeah, he's uh,
one of the most impressive guys I've
ever seen in terms of like when he starts
locking something up, you know, it's
over game over like whoa. Came over.
Just super high level.
Very interesting because it doesn't have
like world championship, uh, you know,
victories in his past, right? No, he
didn't come up through like the IB Jff,
whatever the hell it is. Or he didn't
go to metamorphs anything like that.
He's just this kid that grew up on the
Gracie mats and over time was that kid
who was just like, God damn, he's good.
And just kept with it, kept with it,
kept with it.
Now the crazy thing is,
is striking has become
just as deadly fluid.
Crack Frankie Edgar with an elbow
like that and then starch in with that
uppercut. That's like, he can do
that to standing now off his feet.
Yeah. Yeah. It was, it had to be. So
where's the, where's the picnic picnic?
It's not standing. Not Right. And
I helped pull for Max Holloway.
He's probably looking at going the picnic
for me standing cause he's so God damn
you know good at it.
But you can't just say that's a huge
advantage anymore after you see or take a,
just remember he's knocked out
clay Greta with knees, you know.
Now after you knock out
Frankie Edgar like that,
you like least have to acknowledge the
kids can do some standup damage. I think.
Yes,
but I think there's a real concern with
if they're going to try to fight in July
with Halloween, not having enough
time to recover. I hope I'm wrong,
but when I'm looking at that, when you
just said that it's march and I was like,
yeah, it is march isn't it
began in Montreux, may, June,
July. That's four months.
How do they have, how, how he healed
up? Are you after four months,
are you ready to throw kicks and get
your foot checked? Well who knows?
Maybe they also tour, maybe Dana told or
Brian like, hey, we're shooting for Mars.
We're shooting for July summer,
something like that.
But they don't realize where Mac tall,
you know how this goes.
Maybe it's on another car.
Maybe I'm wrong though. Maybe.
I mean six weeks is what it takes for
bone to heal max a tweet us or something.
Be like, yeah, I'm good right now. Bitch.
Google what it takes for a healthy,
what is Max like 28?
No,
27th sec on him and Brian
or tell you the same age.
20 couple of young bucks something.
Yeah.
And this won't be the last time you see
a brighter taking Max Holloway fight.
What's that?
It's 26
26, sorry, 27. Um, go to uh,
how long does it take?
Just Google.
How long does it take for a bone on a 26
year old man to heal and they cut it in
half because Max Holloway. Yeah, that's
either you don't have the doctors.
She going to be about six months. Well
yes, if I'm a soccer mom, six months.
For me it's going to be about three. Thank
you sir. I'm going to push it at three.
You giant pussy.
That's also a way to blow out
those ACO reach that top doctors.
Are these still all these old people
and like you were out for about a year.
That's true. Three months. Dog Kick
rocks. You know what man, this uh,
tended to engines injury that I got. I
got Golfer's elbow. That really made me,
I'm aware there's a difference between
injured a muscle and an injury,
an attendant hundred percent.
They don't have much blood supply man.
It's that fucking average in
the Dick to get that to heal.
I'm stunned at how long it takes and how
many different things I've done when,
since you told me that I was doing
pull ups in a striver hurting here,
I've stopped doing for a little bit
cause I don't want to just hear,
it's just this,
it started hurting in there and that's
when the here and now I'm like, you know,
I'm a chill out on that stuff.
I got a chunk of something
floating around there too.
You get like a piece of
hard something or another.
I fell once and Alaska,
Collin and I were on this deer hunting
trip and I slipped off the side of a
cliff and cracked my elbow in this rock.
And it was hurting for months afterwards.
Like every time I would do a chin up,
it would hurt and I just sucked it up
and I think I might have chipped a piece
of bone off in there.
I think there's something floating or
it's a piece of calcium that's built up
because of, uh, irritation that can
happen. But it ride, Bro. Yeah, Bro.
You got this man bro. Science dude.
Speaking of people getting fucked up.
How about that girl side work?
But she looks good.
When she got hit with the first
one, her eyes were like, oh my God.
And God bless her man. Because your
first fight in UFC, hey go this.
This is what you always wanted.
Here's Cyborg main event.
Short notice. Enjoy that.
Yeah, that's kind of a
crazy thing to do, right?
Title shot your first fight ever in the
UFC title shot the first fight ever.
And nobody knows. Literally nobody in
the UFC knows who you are. You'll see it.
Even have a picture up of her till the
week of the fight. You've never, uh,
I mean she got submitted by Tanya
evenger. It's tough. She submitted,
Tanya and Tanya submitted her and we
know that she's a one 30 Fiverr. Yeah,
that's her like wincing in pain as Cyborg
lowers the boom CyBorD down though.
She did that weird. Yeah. Well
that was obviously the strategy.
The strategy was to close the distance,
get that clinch drag side work to
the ground. She's a one 35 or man,
she really is not big enough,
but for cyber it's like,
what do you want me to do,
man?
Like there's no one in the division.
What is stopping that Megan Anderson
check from coming over her work visa.
She shows here she was here
illegally or something like that. No,
that was the hold up there.
Oh, some bullshit lawyers
cause on the, I know, man,
let's go. Cause she, she's
a legit, you know, big girl.
Pretty Australian fight. Her
ass all tattooed up. She's
actually the one, you know,
she's in the same weight class
and she wants to fight.
Cat Zingano wanted the fight too.
She's talking all that shit for real
one called Trump. I can't get it done.
God wants to fight. We'll cat
Zingano did what? The cyborg fight.
But since she lost that last one,
beer Catlin split decision.
You Ain't getting sideways not
sniffing. No, no, no, no, no, no.
There's no way she's going to
have to get a couple of it.
Cause she lost her last one too. She
took Julianna Pena. Yeah. And she, she,
she's taken too much.
You could see the ring rust was there
and the nerves are there. She just, she,
she needs time. She has time. She
can compete there with Cyborg. I,
I'm trying to be funny here. She's not
going to lose to single woman. You need,
she needs to fight to women or
that needs to be a dude in there.
But one girl's not going to beat her. I
hate to tell you guys like it's just not,
I don't know how you're
going to market that.
You're telling me you
wouldn't watch her cm punk.
Well I think you put her as co main event
a lot on some cards that have a lot of
great fights. I just think that
people are always going to give,
willing to watch whoever
steps in and fights are,
but to have her be the
center of a giant event,
I think it's going to take a
real challenger like Holly.
Those ratings were good.
Yeah, that was a good fight because that
was a fight where people are like, hmm,
Holly, you know, is legit.
Like real skillful box shows you how good
the decision. Although she, you know,
Holly was never really winning that
fudge, but maybe once a month shot. Yeah,
she got lit up. You realize when
you're in there fighting Cyborg,
it's totally different proposition.
You know when you,
when you see cyber you're just like,
oh man,
she's never going to
lose until father time,
I guess touches around the
shoulder right now she's only 32
crazy. It's not young, but it's not
old either. No, she's not at all.
She prime [inaudible] for another
five years. Easy. When you know,
you think about how
long she's been around,
like way back to the Geno Carano
find. How old was she then? Jesus man,
super young. Super Young. She's
been doing it for a minute.
Did you ever watch that fight again?
It's not bad fight.
People don't give enough credit. No.
Gina mounted or at one point in time to,
you know, first team all diabetes captain.
The team. Yeah, it was pretty hot.
But out of respect and Kevin Ross,
this will be the end of this conversation
when it comes to how hot is that a man?
What's he do? Kevin Ross.
Muy Thai fighter. Oh yeah.
With all, he's all tatted up.
They're still together? Yeah.
Good for them. Good for them.
Hopefully she'll hear it
cause the fight. Yeah, she's,
she's got to be very cool
because he's very cool.
They're this the beginning of fine.
She's just teeing off on June.
She takes her down and fucks up
and Gino ones up on top of her.
Look at Gina doing where people
forget how good that girl was. Men,
how she's very good.
Look at the Cyborg.
You should give her royalties were
starting women's MMA. Let's be real.
Halfassed heel hook here are half decent
heel hook here. She's an attorney.
Get out of it. Actually popped
out yet. Gina. Cronk. I mean,
she just think out big Gina Crown would
be if she was in the sport right now,
Jesus sidebars hit or want some hammers.
This was a,
yeah, she would be gigantic. She'd be so,
because she was Zanup when the
UFC was really in its infancy.
She's big on showtime.
What year do you think his fight was?
If you had to get 20004692000
nine really nine wow.
Cyborg vicious kicks to the body.
So cyber was only like, what,
22 ish or take down your shot again and
this time Gina amounts or look at that
like people forget genus. Getting
them out because sideboards mistakes,
but still mal.
Yeah.
This the most troubling you've ever seen
Cyborg in besides that Moy Thai fight
and gene's going to let her up.
No, Gino was an absolute monster.
People forget man. But with cyber I, I'm
dead serious. I'm even trying to be funny.
Women enter that octagon against her.
She's not going to lose or do you need
to get Khabib up in that bitch? Well,
she obviously has some
physical attributes. Now,
when you think about the rest of the
women at one 45, no one stands out.
What they're gonna do as Amanda
Nunez. That's the fight. Yeah,
I may have missed wants it.
Cyborg wants it.
I liked to fight and I think technically
Amanda Nunez is better as far as a
technician as Cyborg. However,
for let's say that's five rounds,
even three rounds over those
three rounds, she, she,
I don't think she possesses the same
power as Cyborg. You know what I'm saying?
They'd be Cyborg kits. A girl,
you see it on their face.
The stoppage of Gina Carano we're
watching on the big screen. It's horrific.
It's tough one.
And it's horrific when she gets her down
like the hammers that she drops on her
of a Cyborg Fan. I'm more of cyber fan
now. Back then I was first team all Gina.
No one wanted that. No one wanted that.
Did she tests positive for this fight?
Uh, no. I thought it was after this
another five that was in this fight.
That'd be way bigger than news. But,
um, cyborg. Amanda A. Good fight.
That's a really good,
I just in how I'm a huge Amanda Nunez Fan.
I just think over that time she's
going to land some shots on sidewalks.
I won't get hit, but when
cyborg kitchen, it's,
it's just he can't play
that game with her. There's,
there's no female in the world.
He can play that game with her.
You give me one off lake when you hear,
you hear, it just doesn't work. Dude.
Who knows? Man, that's interesting.
It's a great fight though.
Amanda's got legit one punch power,
legit smack him up.
Power real black belt in Jujitsu. Very
good at fighting. Knows how to fight.
Phenomenal fighter. Yeah.
She knows how to fight.
Forget about all the things that she
can do. She puts it together. Well,
you know who can fight
Cyborg. Cyborg. Yup.
She's the greatest female fighter
of all time. It's hard to argue.
It's hard to argue, right? Yeah. It's
hard to argue. Did some caveats in there,
obviously, but it's hard to
argue evenly. Yeah. Yeah.
There's some caveats I guess
really to go down that road.
But still in the UFC with the Usada
testing, she's still the best.
So that kind of takes out of the window.
We'll choose the best back then
and she tends to as hot. Cool.
Now she's in the strict thing,
the most strict testing pool of all time.
She's still dominating. So where's
your argument there now? Well,
you know the argument that she
retained all the shit from when she was
taking it back in the day,
retain something.
I'm not everything though as
Hector Lombard to question
ask Vic doorbell. Right.
That's true. But the, those are men.
It's different. The idea of, you know,
a guy taking shit or a girl taking it,
don't you think they're different? It's,
it's different, but it's also, it's
different. There's argument there,
but it's not different to the point where
after tea was that 2009 you sentences.
So after nine years she's still retaining
this muscle mass and she was born a
bigger female. That's
true too. That's true too.
Like no matter what Gabby Garcia did, she
still six four, correct? She'll giant.
Did. She was at the UFC. I was like Ho
Lee. Shit. You're scared. Terrifying.
Should way too vague for terrified all
of them. She's so big. Do you see she,
she wasn't sitting like a lady.
So it's security to come behind you
and DC and stuff in front of her.
She can't sit like a lady.
She's got long legs. She might,
they know when to ask though.
Cause she's crossing those legs bro.
I just too much done this.
So they're so big. Yeah.
So have you have like
one of them super tank,
crossfit squat girls, those giant
legs, the blonde ass and the quads.
Can they even cross their legs? I'm sure.
How could they cross cross your legs?
Yes. Yes. Legs. I cross. My legs
is comfortable and I get along.
I got to tear it back.
They'll date.
I don't think doc is a big decks.
You Might wanna change that one up.
But the Burger, they have tails.
Do they, I don't know bird there.
Our bird. They're not a dinosaur.
Well they're not a dinosaur. Yeah.
Did you know that? They're in a class
of themselves was telling me that.
My Kid told me that. Oh,
that's right. Seven year old.
See this this way right here.
This is uncomfortable. It's
fonts. So comfy or nut cruncher
us. I'm so comfortable.
Yeah, but you got an extra foot of
leg. Yeah, there's a lot of room here,
but with get with Gabby Garcia.
Remember when she was like,
like big bloated girl and she got shreds.
Shreds city for patrol. Oh, totally.
Misread city. And then she backed the
in between. She's back to giant again,
I think. Why not try and cut the
45 what are you talking about?
Who? She's six 80 do you know? She's
six. Four I'm in the UFC or not
[inaudible] 70 to make it. She's good
friends with Cyborg to look how big. Okay.
She was when she got some all and
helping. She is now two. Shit's hot.
When she was small, she wasn't
bad. Callan. That's what I saw.
That's what I saw in the
air. Like look at that. Oh,
that's when she was on the
ultimate fighter with Vandelay.
I wonder where she's at mentally
when she sees her stuff.
Like does she date that? Cause a lot of
dudes are into that. She can't go online.
Like I like I had a friend
who's a female bodybuilder.
Dick Thicker than a snicker is definitely
deca. Gold's gym, just interacting,
get just protein powder
seeping out of a goddamn eyes.
Get that pink one above it to the right
above, above and to the right. Okay.
That's not mad at all. Not Mad at
it at all. So at one point in time,
in the recent future,
she got down to the body of a really
hot crossfit.
How much did she weigh there though?
She's probably still a thousand pounds.
Six foot four main bro.
She I what do you think? What?
60 there? No, I bet she's there.
She's 200 bro. She's not 200 accounts
there. I bet she's 200 don't you Jamie?
Jamie. She's 64 come on bro.
Okay. Maybe she's one 95 but I'm not going
any lower than that. That's a big girl.
She is.
She's a legit six floor.
Pretty sure Pinal how tall she is.
She's stronger than me.
That's whatever. But there's some
dudes that there's a market for that.
I got a friend who was a bodybuilding,
she was busy cause she would do some
little bit strange for some change and get
oil down. She's always
takes two. I'm sorry,
two 36 six two we can make one 45
she's going to lose a hundred pounds.
Nobody. Real jobs going say why I got you.
What would,
what do you think would happen if she
just got completely off of everything and
just ran marathons?
What do you think she'd get down to?
I don't think she lowered to 36 to two
36 look at the fucking size of her.
Probably one 17 Jesus Christ. Look at
that girl. I'm going to death, right? No,
this poor girl. Good to see.
Did you see her beat up though?
Do you see a beat up the
grandma? Yes. With a knee brace.
He beat up a grandma and a knee brace,
bro. So wrong struggle city. I hear,
here's her like, first of
all, she's really good at
Jujitsu by the way. Phenomenal,
right? Mackenzie during her matches. Yeah.
Mckenzie beat her on points. How crazy.
That's how bad ass Mckenzie dearness.
She poked his chick apparently,
and they found that checkout fake.
Like, I get poke too. Yeah, good move.
I'd fall down.
I'd black out how she's rushing though.
They can't and she'll get murdered.
She gets back to really get in there.
Someone's got a bet.
I have bit to make it to one minute
survive any way you can for fun. We need,
dude, I just boom. How do they not
have her fight? Dude's like, oh,
that's it. Oh good move for
her. No more. It can go.
The fight has gone one minute that my
obligation is over here to think about her
research. Cyborg, perverse,
Cyborg, Cyborg, or fuck her up.
Jeff Novitsky cycle hike
for a couple of weeks.
So much better standing up than her.
She would have to take cyborg
down and cyborg would fuck her up.
So when she went to watch that now really
for obvious reasons that we can't talk
about. Look at that. There she
is right there. Palm Palm Palm,
but legit black belt in Brazilian Jujitsu.
You can say whatever you want about it,
but the girl works her ass,
her ass off no matter what.
No matter what you take,
you don't get that big
unless you're training hard.
She's just dropping bombs in this check.
Her striking has gotten a lot better,
lot more smooth and relaxed. Like she was
having a hard time when she first got,
Ooh,
Jesus shared tagged that Leah to
Tapa is doing work. She would say,
oh, she got attacked again.
Damn. Her striking is terrible.
Well, she's hurt. She's
hurt. She's well, but this
is what got me. Joe, look at this chick's
going, come on, come on. Come on Sarah.
Come to center. Damn. She's like, bring
it. She'd get a little emotional though.
That rise in just free for all
and I shade it. So gangster,
they're so gangster. They're trying
to bring back the golden days.
I now you know what that day is over.
So kind of give it a rest,
but I like what they're doing. You
see belt or brought cro, cop back.
The Cro cop Roy. I just don't tell. We've
seen that just on test. Anybody please.
I just couldn't, I don't know.
Don't know. Don't just stop testing.
I'll say with the John Jones thing against
Brock Lesnar. Hey Jeff. Novitsky let's,
uh, go grab a cup of coffee
while these boys rumble. Huh?
Do we Levine while we
go? Why don't you go, go,
go on vacation to Hawaii while John
and Brock take a little a tripper.
The UFC is clean,
but it doesn't have to be UFC.
UFC decided to go down that you sought
a road and they've committed to it.
It's changed the game legitimately
for sure. Let's be honest,
when you've been fucking life,
I've got a legend like cro cop.
He still wants a fight.
Excuse me.
That'll help if a hundred or so up mom,
that's real.
I'm not saying he needs it. I'm not,
I'm not, it's not a knock on him.
He's upset at me because a bas Rutten
was saying that during one of his fights
that uh, they paid him all this money and
they had to bring all this money back,
like bosses explaining at the bottom
into a room and say, boss said it,
but he thinks that I said because it was
on your show. Yeah, it was on my show.
I didn't know what my boss was going to
say and if I heard anything about it,
I heard it from boss cause boss worked
there and bosses just fucking hilarious.
And he's telling me about how
they would pay those guys in cash.
Well he doesn't like you.
He likes me and I punched him in the face.
So me and him are friends,
but I just want him to know I'm
a big Fan Heli Pad for Cro cop.
I always enjoyed watching
him and he's the,
the example that I always use of what
happens when you get an explosive striker
versus a technical striker in MMA.
I think when you get a high level
striker that's used to a certain style of
fighting and then they fight
an MMA, sometimes that style
doesn't translate over.
Like I don't think Peter Arts would
have done that good as an MMA fighter.
I don't think Ernesto hoost would have
done that good because they would have to
have changed the way they strike because
there are so technical and it really
fun to watch fight and
they would bra for sure.
But what Merkel would do was
have these big one shots,
these big one kicks,
he's big one punches,
just jump in with one
shot super fast and quick.
That is really beneficial in MMA more
so even than kickboxing because it's the
volume the he's fighting guys who are,
um,
it at the time were,
they were concerned about take downs.
You concerned about all these different
things that could possibly happen in an
MMA fight.
Right.
So no one stands the way they stand
in kickboxing when they're standing in
kickboxing there more sideways,
they're more light on their feet.
They're moving around cause they don't
have to worry about being taken down.
It's a totally different proposition.
It's also a dance in a rhythm. Yeah.
So guy like host. Yeah, guy like
who's would just pick you apart,
start leg kick and you chopping down.
If he's got to think about takedowns even
really great strikers are susceptible
to one pot shots in MMA because there's
so many more things you're thinking of.
That's why Kevin random and crack cro
cop and knocked them out of their fight
because he's got to
worry about the takedown.
Like if they were just in a kickboxing
fight. Kevin Randleman and Cro cop,
Justin Kay,
one nightmare.
It's a nightmare for Kevin about
Wonderboy Woodley Wonderboy all day.
They going to kickboxing match all day.
Wonderboy light him up,
Woodley that one shot power and
he dropped, you know one a boy,
you know before I say that
even in kickboxing Woodley
I think would do very well
because he's so powerful and, and
you'd be able to manage it more though.
You be to gloves so you catch more.
And also his punches aren't as dangerous.
So when he's hitting you,
it's not as dangerous. You can
catch the kicks a little bit better.
It's still not fun. Hell, no wonder
boys. Octagon is a nightmare.
We're not one shot power.
Yeah. Those little gloves got
hopefully fight soon, man.
He's going to, he's a, he had shoulder
surgery at a torn labrum, so he's,
he's pounding on that,
trying to get that fixed up.
He dos Anjos that's what
they're going to do.
Maybe they'll do that
international fight week to dawn.
Dawn Sizzla,
which I can get these
ratings up for Fox buys.
WWU imagine if Brock's first fight
back as John Jones. Yeah, I can. Yeah,
I can see what I'm just a car. Don't
look all the fucker. It's not July. Yes.
Yes.
Steep a DC Granshawn Jones.
Brock preach, Tyron Woodley.
Dosen Joe's or Tayga.
Max Holloway. Amanda Nunez. Cyborg.
We bust in this load on
this one card you can get.
We can still do. The ratings did
that. That place would be insane.
That'd be insane. That'd be one of
the greatest cards of all talkers.
And then on top you sprinkle
in the swingle cm punk.
You wouldn't be able to do that one. Why?
Because that one needs so much money.
The one that I'm thinking about, which
one? You know the one, which one? Joe?
The one that was a lot of sprinkles on
top, which was, you know that boxer guy,
what's his name? Are you talking about
Floyd money that we keep talking about?
If that happened? This is, by the way,
I believe you and I were the first
speculate. That's publicly correct.
I think that's the fight. I think
that's the fight to make. I agree.
I don't know if it'll ever happen,
but I think it, if it does happen,
it happens on its own individual card.
You put a kickass card underneath it,
but I don't know if you put like a UFC
200 size kickass Carter anything. No.
Cause Floyd and cm punk skin cell.
And also if you're Floyd just
lean up from Floyd's perspective.
I pay me this much money,
which I boatload of cash and also give
me the guy who has zero experience like
me and cm punk comes with a huge name,
so it makes sense.
It's the only fight to make for Floyd
cause condo literally kill them. Yeah,
you can't do that. It wouldn't
be fair. It's not fair.
[inaudible] light up Floyd
into bunk in the same night.
People would understand the difference
between Connor Boxing Floyd,
which you've got clearly outclassed,
but he hit him like, Floyd's,
I can do anything. No, it's
no competition. It doesn't.
It's going to be awful.
It doesn't make sense. Make sense? He'll
get kicked once in the legs and be like,
oh my God, now I can't walk. And then he
gets kicked in the same spot. I'm like,
oh Jesus Christ. And his folding over
and he's getting front kicked in the gut.
Connor's talking shit to him.
Get head kicked.
The bishop and then you're
on that highlight reel and
the UFC is using that over
loop over and over.
And then it takes one clinch.
Just one clench and
you're on on your back.
If your cm punk than her fighting Floyd,
I'm army crawling over flooded.
You're not even go ahead and punch me,
but say Stan karate style.
He stand karate style and you throw
sidekicks and you just walk towards him
throwing sidekicks. There's
so many just to the cage. Yes.
Why would you even want to box him?
He stand total Wonderboy side
stance to stand like this,
way back Liotta Machida style
and just throw sidekicks,
keep them off you and then when
the move is, whenever it happens,
get that clinch it rock
fucking everything.
The guy weighs 145 legitimate pounds.
That's what Floyd ways.
Even just bear hug him and just pull
them on top of me and sweep them and get
full amount. I would literally
just come at Floyd like this.
Just walked straight
forward like the terminator.
Floyd can make it a welterweight. He could
make welterweight and boxing. He could.
That's the only problem with this fight
that we're speculating is 20 pounds of
weight. Are they going to fight it?
Cause see a punks nuts wall? No,
he was a legit sized one 70 so he
would go and catch weight here.
You'd have to be catch weight
60 see that's the other thing.
You Drain cm punk down to one 60 and
he's Foxville. Yeah, let's do that. Yeah.
Well,
well here's the thing.
It at one 70 he doesn't
have a lot of muscle,
but he's got a little bit
of fat so maybe can do,
he might be able to do 65 he
does it smart and long, you know,
he takes a long time to do it. Adjust
as calories, really ramps up as cardio.
Just forces himself to do an hour of
cardio after every training session.
Has anyone seen him lately?
Other man looked in thinner? No.
It's going to have to look a lot thinner
to get that fight or Floyd's. He says,
I don't give a fuck. I'm going to light
this dude up. Cause when they're standing,
when? When he's got to close
the distance on cm pie,
Floyd has four ounce gloves on.
Are you fucking kidding me?
And he's impossible to hit. He's in
pot. You're not going to hit them.
That's not happened to catch coming in
and it's gonna beat fucking night night.
Even the leg kicks like, boy,
can you even kick his legs?
How fast the CM punk kick.
You know what I mean?
We're not talking about like yachts and
Clyde. That's not the move for cm punk,
sir. Just do what you gotta do to get to
the ground. We have a karate background.
Cm punk. Yes. Much as a, I have a crowded
and I'm not making fun of ill of him
when he was like 13 or some shit and I
guess does it count?
I play dodge ball to when the band,
I had a resume not on my resume.
Doesn't count. Soccer player.
I'm going to put that on my fucking
soccer players. My Twitter handle
now I play. That doesn't
count man. Play it. Yeah,
we were hit so heartbroken man. You're
right. Jesus. I don't want to throw it.
It's that cold brew. This new Cobra
was snacking on. God Damn. Jamie,
what were you showing me right
before the podcast started?
About some dude who just retired
because he had a brain injury. Oh yeah,
there's a,
an NFL running back.
It was just seeing the story so
I don't know too much about it,
but I know who he is. His name is beanie
wells. He was a running back in the NFL.
Um, he had an MRI and
it's showing brain injury,
so he's starting his already publicly
stating he's having problems with that.
He was having memory loss,
speech problems. How old is
this gentleman? 29 I think.
Oh Man.
Yeah man.
He's already going under
treatment right now, so like he's,
he would be one of the first people
I've heard of that is already getting
treatment for what I guess they can tell
now about potential, so what do they do?
How do, how are they treating
it? There he is handsome fellow,
former cardinals are be beanie wells
dealing with traumatic brain injury,
so they know for a fact that he has it,
so he must be one of the recipients of
one of the newer tests that allows them
to see while the person's
alive because it used to be,
they used to have to do an autopsy autopsy
to find out what's wrong with what's
wrong with your brain.
There's this quote,
he says he has plot some
plaques separation [inaudible].
It shows that you've experienced some sort
of Tbi and says when you have plaques.
Yeah. Separation shows you've
experienced some traumatic brain injury?
Obviously that traumatic injury for
me would come from playing football.
Not only that,
they had some cells tacked on to that
separated plaque that I needed to get
under control. What does that mean?
You think? I mean, extra cells.
I only know as being bad cancer,
cancer type stuff. Right.
Still on out of the woods yet, but I'm
hopeful. Wow. Well, at least he sees it.
Right. You know, and he, he got ahold
of it. Now, when did he stop playing?
Uh, pretty recently. And he
would also be in Columbus,
which would be at Ohio
state where they have the,
not only like the James Cancer plays,
but I think they're doing the tests are
some of the early tests on this. Oh,
remember correctly? You even told me it
was at Ohio state. Maybe not. I don't,
I don't know. I talk too much. I forget
some of the Shit I say. I really do.
I've realized that, um, when
someone asked me what podcast,
I'm Eric Weinstein and,
uh, Heather hying we're on,
and I had to think about it,
it's like 1080. [inaudible]
and I thought about, look,
how the fuck could I ever remember
what I said, if they were all one hour
a thousand different conversations
plus fight companions or this is,
I think it is Ohio state.
There's a thing,
and this is on their medical Wexner
center medical website. They have, uh,
advanced imaging and neuro sensitive
care and Rehab services. Right?
We're talking brain trauma. Yeah. We're
talking about that football player that,
um, just got tested. He had
plaque separation and his brain.
How long did he play for Jamie?
Uh,
so probably about seven years
I think in the NFL. He's off.
See the exception though, you know,
there's obviously a prom, but he's,
he's definitely the exception. I wonder,
you know, mom's around for so long,
it's been around for so long. I think a
lot of people just live with it, you know,
and did the thing is um,
what does that apo a three apo e three
something that Rhonda Patrick was talking
about like a, it was a gene, like
somehow the way it expresses itself.
Um, I know I'm butchering this for
the science people going crazy,
but science people,
it's more likely that you would get a
traumatic brain injury if you have it or
you do not have is actually tests
for the timers. Disease. Yeah.
Early onset Alzheimer's.
Yeah.
There's a test you can take to see if
you're more susceptible to us CT than
others. Yeah. Here it is.
It says there are three types of apo e
genes called Ailes allows apo e two e
three e three and e four.
Everyone has two copies of the gene in
the combination that terms your apo geno
type. Um, the [inaudible]
Lal, I hope not. Fuck that up.
Probably am fucking hell.
L E l e right is the rarest form the APO
e and carrying some one copy appears to
reduce the risk of developing
Alzheimer's by up to 40%. Whoa.
Apo e three is the most common Lao
and doesn't seem to influence risk.
The APO e four Lal,
I know I'm fucking that word up.
Someone's screaming at their phone right
now present and approximately 10 to 15%
of people increases risk for all
timers and lowers the age of onset.
That's what I think they think is
connected to traumatic brain injury.
I think it was apo e
four whatever gene I got.
I've been knocked out so many times.
I'm happy as fuck cause that one,
whatever that is, get that one.
It's made me so much happier.
Well aren't you happy though,
because your life is going great.
Don't you think that's a factor?
I think there's something,
there's something to be said
for that that people don't look.
Everybody knows that having
good friends in your life,
having a good relationship,
having a family and having a
career that you're happy with,
all those things make you feel good.
It's one of the reasons
why people strive for them.
Don't you think that that has an
impact on overall happiness? I think,
you know with, with football players and
fighters, MMA box or stuff like that.
I think one of the advantages I have is
I found my passion and I'm in pursuing
that so I don't, you know, it keeps
me happy and it keeps my brain,
I have to be super creative
so it's keeping me sharp.
I think a lot of athletes and soldiers
for that matter that they get done with
this high stress high,
you know,
rush a job and they get put in
the real world and they can't,
they can't find their lane
and it's, oh, it's PTSD or oh,
it's brain trauma at CT now
you're just depressed man.
Because you went from being the superstore
for doing this high level job to fit
in with siding out. It's tough. Well,
I don't think it's, no you're not.
I think it's both. It's a factor.
It's a factor, but it's not. It's,
there's a lot of physical factors. 100%
gel. I'm just saying I've around blasts
100% 100% that's a legit issue.
I'm just saying if,
if people are as fortunate as me to go
through this sort of traumatic fighting
career and then find a passion, your
true passion, you'd be way better off.
And I have no advice for that.
I don't know what to tell you,
but if you could find something you're
into, it's definitely gonna help you.
I think for everything in life,
you know, if you were a dentist,
so you didn't want to be a dentist
anymore and you really wanted to make
paintings, if you could have, you could
really figure out a way to do that.
You'd be happier.
Like whatever that thing is.
It's just really hard for
some people to find a thing.
And that's one of the things that I've
talked to people. They go, I don't,
I don't really know what
I want to do with myself.
And then they asked me for
advice. My man, no one told me.
It doesn't really work like that.
Like you got to figure that out.
There's literally not a book you can read
and we can talk to that's gonna point
you in the right direction. Here's
the, here's the best piece of advice.
Take some action, take some action,
do something. If that doesn't work,
correct it, find something else.
But keep, keep moving, keep moving.
When you're sitting at home going, what
do I do? That's when it's a problem.
And when you're texting your friends
going, hey, got any advice for me?
My advice to you is don't ask me for
advice. Don't DME, DME for advice.
Shit together. I don't do that to people.
I don't call people up and say, hey man,
which they do. I just do things
correct. Just go do something. Agree.
And it might not be the thing
you might say. Ah, okay,
well now I know I don't want to do that.
You could try something out.
Don't be afraid to fuck up though. I fuck
up all the time. You got to got it down.
You've got to take risks. You
got to, people are so scared.
They want to be in that harbor.
Want to stay safe?
Keep me under the blanket cushions.
Oh that's north.
Which is weird cause I take risks when
it comes to my family and my friends.
Even with Brian or Tayga. I'm like, don't
do this. Don't do that. I'm super light.
But with myself, I'm pretty reckless. But
with them I'm like, no, no, no, no. Wait,
please wait. Just strange. What do
you think is steep, pained and DC?
I think it's literally the greatest
super fight the UFC has ever made.
I'm so excited for it.
It's an amazing fight when you see a how
well DC handled Volk on olds demeanor
and you see what Steve Bay did to Francis.
It almost like makes sense while
John is out and Brock is busy,
thrown his piss into a microwave,
he's got that same pump system that
I use out there and my flip day,
he pinches into that thing.
They strain that bitch.
And the reason why it's a super fight
twos, because how tough is this car,
this fight to break down? Like
if someone's like, I'm positive,
steep is going to win. You're
like, no, you're not on positive.
DC is going to take him down. No,
you're not. And the thing is it's like,
well now dcs, find the heavyweight. Yeah,
he's undefeated heavyweight and
I'm a fucking fight at heavyweight.
He's actually one of the best of you.
It's well done.
Imagine if one day we see Novitsky
he's wearing all diamonds and shit.
Just appalling cleanser. That was
what I would do if I was in bed ski.
If with the day Brock
Lesnar gets in the UFC,
I will show up in a full fur coat with
a giant diamond encrusted cross pimping,
pimping pimp diamonds on every finger,
Gucci sunglasses indoors
and just sit there.
Nobody told me how to dress.
Just sit there like gay. Got.
We did another one.
It was just sit in his cage side.
Imagine just like, that's the way to do
it. So everybody knows like super obvious.
If you have to bet on a Joe John Jones,
Brock Lesnar the fights happening. Huh?
Boy I hope so.
Yeah,
I hope so. I if I was Brock, I
wouldn't take that fight. Really?
No.
Get a fight under your belt first.
We don't have time for that bullshit.
There's don't warm up as
Brock Lesnar fight warmup. I
know. It's really hilarious.
Francis. Oh Jesus. What do
you want to do? The poor man.
I'm going to w Frances or Brock
Brock. If I'm Bronx. Excuse me sir.
I'm blast doubling luck.
I'm at fucking Minnesota.
You right through that
chiller or in the first round.
Francis is superhuman.
Freak strong,
and you got to wear them out
before you could take them down,
but you have to stay conscious long
enough to where I'm out for. You.
Take them down and he's throwing new,
clear Putin style fucking head,
and when they land,
you're gonna see sparks.
That's going to remind you of Alistair
Overeem and you're going to go, holy fuck.
You play that game. If you play that
game. I fought Brock Lesnar. I am blasto.
I'm coming with a single it on on blast.
Definitely through Francis.
Brock is older.
He's,
he'd be the best wrestler
that France has ever faced.
Who's that? Stevie Brock. No, Brock.
Brock's the best rest of that thought.
You say he beat the best.
I'm saying it'd be the best wrestler
that Francis ever fought. Oh,
that's a problem. Oh yeah, for
sure. It's also ginormous, right?
But he doesn't have the standup at Acumen.
That's deep bay does.
Like Brock is just not as good in the
stand up. We don't need any of that.
So you definitely need a little Nah,
you gonna need a little Nah liquid.
Allister did. Allister kept him
off. Remember that for a hot second.
Then I also want to play the
rock 'em sock. 'Em robots
and got flatlined. No, no.
When Alister beat up. Oh Guy. We're
talking about two different alleys.
Jesus Christ sir.
How dare you tell her how it to burrim
talking about the Uber took Bro, don't we?
It was a moment in time when you and I
get together with my mouth salivates we
talking about Uber. It was a
moment in time. A special moment.
He was the scariest man on earth. Yeah,
there was. He was. It was a weird moment.
It was like, wait a
minute, what? This is real.
How has that kind of that
thing I was fighting then too.
It kind of feel like it's a bad idea.
Well, not only that, call his doctor,
he had already won the k one
ground pre on the strike force.
He's smashed Brett Rodgers.
I mean he was,
he was just beating the fuck out of
people, man. Brock was like, what?
It was terrible fight for Brock.
The awful fighting man would take
down a fence and world class striking,
wicked striking.
Like it was a different kind of striking
and it's like a much more tactical
walking juice. Like we're
in fucking pumping out. Ooh,
like you're in fucking, what's
the juice place? Jamba juice.
Like get the fucking job budget,
but he doesn't punch as hard as Francis
that's ubering back then he did.
He's just Louise's no, I don't
think so. I don't know man.
He punched more technical,
very hard. Much more tactical.
But I think Francis has
got some new things.
Here's some powers,
new levels.
The Way Francis punches you is like,
it's a different level now.
Francis is a complete nightmare.
Haver Brock Lesnar and be an
awful matchup for true. It's true.
But I feel like you got two giant
moneymakers there. That's what I'm saying.
I don't know. Trying to get it right
away. We try and make money or not. Yeah,
but if Brock loses, that's a wrap.
Like if you lose the Francis,
he loses the most terrifying. It's not
like he's going on a 10 year run here.
We're just trying to get our money. Oh,
look at before and after. That's crazy.
As Christ 2009 to 2016 whoa.
That's amazing.
Testosterone is real people. That's
more testosterone. That's that.
That's that John, but not having,
it's real too. We're sure. Yeah.
Tough mentally to, yeah. There's
not much you can do either.
The other thing about it is like once
your body doesn't produce anymore and
you're in your late thirties like that
and you've been juicing for a long time,
it was like Clomid and stuff that
tries to or to read each CT or HTC.
What's true? Is that a mood that's a
cell phone either way, hcg or something,
whatever it is, but supposed to
boost your testosterone naturally,
but never to the levels when you're
injecting that John. But juice, no,
not only that though. You can't take
that stuff to in the UFC. It's illegal.
I'm just saying when, yeah, that's
true. When I guess when he retires,
he can do whatever the
fuck he wants. Yeah, yeah.
When he retires or goes to a rise in Kim,
imagine UFC lets him out of the contract
and then all of a sudden he disappears
for like eight months and just we here
just locked in the house and ports horse
meat back,
just just filet of horse all day.
He's eating that Canelo meat and goes
back to dead lift and hanging out with
power lifters. Steps out of the fucking
house in Holland. Six months later,
Dick tied around [inaudible] 97 yes.
Yeah. I want that journey for him.
I want that because I went on board of
that train is only one way can happen,
dude.
How about Kelly and hot for fucking
Clenbuterol and they're saying it's in the
meat in Mexico. It is a small trace
amounts and everyone's like, oh,
the fights off. Trust me, it's
boxing. That flight is not off.
There's way too much money involved.
That is a real fact though,
is that one particular substance he
tested positive for exists in meat
Clenbuterol yeah,
and also it's not like a straight steroid,
you know guys use it to cut weight and
stuff like that and it's such a small
trace amount. They're going to be
fine. Yeah. That's such a great fight.
Triple g canola man.
It's a very good fight and it's way
better than the first one. Cinco de Maya.
Why do you think it's going to be better?
I cause I,
I think triple g didn't fight
like himself. He wasn't,
he has that mix in style.
He's a little reserved and then you know,
Canelo was moving too much.
I think now that they're going to break,
we're getting like the real fight now.
I don't think the judges fuck this one
up. You never know though. It's shady.
I loved the first fight. I loved it. I
thought let me too. I I thought triple g
one it going away though. I
really thought he won. Me Too.
I think a lot of people did. A lot of
people thought that was a poor draw.
That's why I think,
you know,
Chit with g coming off that drawl now
there's a lot more hype with everyone's
getting tuned in. The ratings are going
to be better. And my boxing judges,
you know, they're crooked. MMA is nowhere
near as bad, but bots like did you,
did you see the wild Ortiz fight?
No,
I thought for sure wilder was losing on
the cars and like he's gonna have to get
a finish. But on actual scorecards
they had wild or winning,
which obviously they want wilder to
win, which I thought was, I was like,
I did and I'm a wilder Dick Rider.
I'm like, he's not looking at fight.
I think they might be worse.
And they're the same exact judges,
a lot of the same judges that judge MMA
that also or judge box and also judge
MMA and they don't even know what MMA is.
UNDC trying to walk that tight rope
of not clown and what's her name?
Abalene she's a very nice lady.
But as you said,
so it was my mom. I don't
want her to fucking piss
exactly what I've nat judging.
That's exactly what I said. It's so fun.
You in DC just trying to balance that.
She has no business being in the,
in the very nice lady. But yeah,
she's made some bad decisions and
she also was a part all in though.
She was also a part of the Canelo Alvarez
triple g decision. That's the problem.
Yeah, she's balling. Yeah.
And she was on the wrong side of
a couple of decisions that night.
There was some,
there was some bad ones.
Super so site to some that we were like
what? How did he win every round? What?
Oh you didn't make any sense like some
that some that literally didn't make any
sense each time I'm in the UFC this past
weekend there was a lot of bad decision.
Bad ones. Yeah. But there was like a
couple of split decisions that I was like,
what in the actual fuck is this?
And the weight screws over
the fine or they have no idea.
The repercussion is such a shitty deal.
Yup. Yeah. They lose half their money.
Money, the money. Cause you don't know
what's going on and literally you,
there's no recourse.
And if it's a bad decision and there's
three people and one person just has
literally no idea what they're doing
and they give it to the wrong person,
it's awful, man. It's fucking terrible
and it's unnecessary. Here's the thing,
it's unnecessary.
There's way better methods.
And one of the most better methods is
one of the better methods is hire someone
who was an actual martial arts expert.
Like I'm Matt Hume or something like that.
Someone does score like,
oh you can,
I'm sure there's a lot of
those guys that would do it.
A lot of trainers out there that
would do it. I think I agree.
You need to have someone who
specialized in mixed martial arts.
She's been around the game. I don't, they
don't need to be Kate side cause cage.
I can't see everything.
And you're also swayed by the crowd.
They shouldn't be in an
undisclosed location and
they're watching what we see in
judging the fight from the MMA fighters
perspective. I think that's a good point.
And I also think they should be
able to see all the replays. Yes,
they should see all the fight stat. So you
get everything, get everything, copies,
strikes and then decide. But what
you're doing now, so old school,
the only thing that I would disagree with,
I don't think they should
hear the commentary because
I think the commentary can
sway. I'm saying no, calm
down. Calm the crowd noise.
You have three expert MMA and
molests watching this. Who's winning?
Cause you're going to, they know
the ground game, you know for that.
For Tony Ferguson, Khabib let's say
could be takes Tony Down and they think,
oh he has a huge advantage and
then Tony's just whooping his ass,
throws back,
elbows submission game stand back up,
getting taken down,
but on the ground could be
constantly under threat.
How are you going to
judge that? How are, yeah,
you gotta know what you're looking at.
I also think three is too small.
I think it should be 10 people,
10 people.
A lot of people can't
qualify to have him call in.
It's a real shit show how to do it all.
Do did it all with the Internet.
You didn't even have to be in the
building to be there. 10 10 people.
It's harder for three more.
Yeah.
But if there's two that are
smart and one that's bad,
you've got a shitty split decision
and everybody feels weird about it.
Like what would have happened
if there was three more on?
So can we say five 10 10 10 you're going
to get the right decision almost every
time because to a few people
are going to disagree,
but most people are gonna see it.
That one majority majority's going
to see it this way and agree.
And if it's five to five,
you've got to fuck a draw in your hands.
And that's rare.
I'm not mad at that.
And I think sometimes a fight
should be a fucking draw.
Draw a problems and watch it
go, man, that's too close. Call.
Don't fuck over Sonia than half their pay.
If there's a draw,
they both get their wisdom.
That's how we should do. Exactly.
One guy moves on and the other guy
doesn't just arbitrarily so weird.
It doesn't make any sense for you to draw
and they have to in their contract it
rematched whatever card the Raby go again.
I do it again.
And the fucking address here. I'm
sure he's texting, you know, count.
He said he's 75 minutes away. He
said he found it. He says he's close.
Is He? I don't believe
that he might be. He could.
And Catlin. Brian Kidd in.
So what else is going on? Um,
the UFC was what's happened. What
other, what other big fights are there?
Um, when Yoel Romero comes in
and talks to a Joey Diaz and me,
he's getting ready to fight
Whitaker. They're gonna, he's gonna,
he's gonna fight for the title,
even though he didn't make weight in
the Rockhold fight. That's short notice.
I don't hold that against them though.
Right. Especially with his body type. God,
he looked good. Get good
against Rockhold. Huh?
Rockhold teddy was like made out of metal.
Said the guy was just ridiculously strong.
Fight Rockhold for anybody. For anyone.
Robert Whitaker. But yeah. Yeah. In
[inaudible] with healthy needs. Man,
there's a nice man. Yeah, he's gonna
be tough to beat for a long time.
But if someone could do it,
could be ELL, but is not young,
40 years old son. Every bit of it. Yeah.
Who knows those Cuban birth certificates.
You have no idea. That's what I
saying with Ortiz. They said, oh,
he's 38 when bullshit. That's the most
shot out. 38 year old I've ever seen.
That man has 400 amateur fights in Cuba.
There's no,
he's 38 to 48 he thinks
so that he's not 38.
There's no way you see him up
close. I'm like, what the fuck?
Did you see him up close? Yeah,
I said the press, uh, the, uh,
the Wayne's all that stuff for shelter.
Did you see the fight live or did
you see it on TV? No, I flew back.
I supposed to work it,
but I flew back.
I watched 'em Kovalev beat up his
friend beat the piss out of his friend.
It was like his friend.
It was like the guy was fighting him
like he was his friend and cove low was
fighting him. Like some guy fucked his
girlfriend. They ass Kobo if killed a guy.
Yeah. And it didn't seem,
don't know mother fucker.
He's a super bad motherfucker.
But
now with that wilder or tease fight,
which was,
it kind of did what I think for wilder.
What Joe Anthony,
Joshua w against Klitschko. We're
now, everyone's stuck around.
So now before we didn't think
we'd get Anthony, Joshua Wilder,
but I think it forces
Joshua's hand to fight.
Wilder was before it wasn't going to
happen, which that's the fight man.
Why wasn't going to happen before?
Because they have the will.
So anti Joshua has to get through
Joseph Parker first, early next month,
which is a beast. Just Parker's a
nightmare from New Zealand, I think.
20 [inaudible], you know,
world champion, no punk.
So he had to get by that and then he
was going to take like one or two more
fights before he fought wilder.
Now you can't do that because
while they're just won by
emphatic. Yeah. Was like,
what are you talking about?
The hops on those talked about box.
Right now you have to take this fight.
Why did they put fights like that off?
Like why do they say, we'll take
a cup that's boxing. Well, listen,
if he has a business, if you're, if
you're Anthony, Joshua was man, just like,
all right, do we fight dot throughout
who's 40 and oh, 39 knockouts.
The nightmare of a fight for anybody,
which we were probably favorites still
to fight or do we fight this guy,
this guy, and get paid and
then fight wilder? You know,
things can go wrong. Exactly.
A heavyweight, Joseph Parker
is no joke. Not at all.
No. But yeah, things could go wrong,
but I'm assuming that's
their way of thinking.
You know what? It's scary.
I, I was jumping around off,
see being around these guys,
you know,
I get close with guys and I know wilder
and I wanted to win so bad just because
it's good for the sport. It's not knocking
Ortiz teaser, amazing fighter, but wild.
He checks all the boxes, man. He can,
he can sell tickets. He's American. He,
you know, he talks a lot of
shit. He has a great story.
Started boxing because his daughter was
born with a spinal issue and couldn't
walk and he just has these great stories
and you want the root for that trust as
well dressed as well.
Diane piece knockout artists,
but him and Josh was the
fight man. Yeah, he has one.
His last couple of fights
pretty spectacularly to
people are so fussy, so mad.
They get so mad at me. They go, oh, oh
my God. Oh, you're such a home, are you?
You love wild. I'm like, well,
I like Joshua to where they're
like used to root for Joshua.
I liked both of them are men can't
respond to those people. I don't respond,
but he can't. Even right now you're
responding well, it's way, it's my job.
You know? We do that thing kind of. Yeah.
You know, I like both of those guys, man.
I love both of them. You can like
both of them. That's when Ferguson,
Tony Ferguson got mad that I put a cubs
hat on. He, Tony, I thought were tall,
10th planet. I'm like, hey bro, I'm
wearing the hat. Guy gives me the hat.
I'm wearing it. I could be, but I like
Tony like or Tayga like Frankie Egg.
Want to see you guys fight. I think
it'd be awesome. You're going to,
there's going to be
animosity. No, no doubt.
If someone doesn't make weight or get
her fired, I'm going to cry. Yeah,
I'm blue every day. When I checked Tony's
Instagram or check Khabib's, I'm like,
please, please, no injuries, no
injuries. Everybody keep it together.
Anything crazy in there? We're not even
a month away. Not even a month away.
Yeah. That's a fight.
Yeah. What is the date?
It's March 6th it's a
month and a day for a month
and a day. Good googly Mowgli. That fight,
that fight is by far my favorite.
The fight has to happen.
It has to reach and it could
be and then steep a DC.
Those are my two fights where I'm just,
I'm literally like the school
blocking card. Key asset versus pedis.
I forgot about that owl.
I Quinta verses Paul Felder.
Are you fucking Shit Dude?
Yolana do Rose Joe Lowe.
Lozan you want to and rose.
Oh my goodness. God Damn.
Evan Dunham still doing the damn
thing and they gave him that monster.
Yeah. Tie some off. Well they couldn't
get an, and trying to fight tight.
They couldn't get married back.
Tie some off a good fight for a long time.
He's very, very directly
that gentlemen. Yeah.
And he's having a real hard time
getting matchups with Evan Dunham.
Doesn't give a fuck.
I bet you anything.
Your boy Connor's there because his boy
Artem low blobs fighting and prednisone.
Khabib makes sense. Yeah.
Lobe Office Fighting Cause
Sarah's, that should be fine.
Hello Bob Fan man. It's tough dude.
Salty record at 14, 14 but that's life.
Yeah,
he's um,
it's interesting because there's two
schools of thought with him and Connor is
that,
you know,
that he's strong and he's powerful and
he's a good sparring partner for Connor.
But I've also heard people say no kind
of likes him because Connor can fuck him
up. And Connor sparks.
Yeah. So God damn tough.
Like having a really tough
sparring partners. Probably
a great idea. Both. Yeah.
He's not exactly a technician, but he
thought, I'm so damn tough. It's hard to,
he hits hard. He said, you got to watch
your p's and q's at all times. He,
I'm sure he's a great training
partner and he's loyal to,
he's not going to hurt you. That's
it. Super important. Oh yeah.
Especially now in Carter's life. That's
got to be real important. And I mean,
how many people were just constantly
trying to get the best of them and so on.
No hashtag no new friends either. There's
no new guy sparring with him. I was, um,
looking at this, uh, this dude,
a couture row on k one here. I'm going
to send it to you, Jamie. This dudes,
they were doing the exact kind of sparring
that I fucking hate to see anyone do
where they were literally just going
at each other out and then, um,
could Taru connected with the
giant bomb and knocked him out.
Yes, he did. It was awful. That's
that old school fighting, man.
I'm going to send this to Jamie. Hang on
a second. Super old school fighting. Well,
it's just,
it's unfortunate when people choose to
train like this because this is a real
out that this guy suffered
and it wasn't an accident.
Like this guy was teeing off on
him trying to knock them out.
I just sent it to you in a text message.
It's not like the guy was
knocked out because um, you know,
he just got caught with a freak punch off
the Gaba and sparring. Watch this shit.
We get those guys in the back of it.
We have this
look at this or they're playing for keeps
and then walks away. Like it doesn't
give a fuck. It's so weird, man. Hey,
don't get out of it. Look at
this guy. Doesn't like that.
Very good. Who he's
fighting. No, no, he doesn't.
And mean he is swinging from the
Oh, that dude's like k owed. Yeah.
He's flatline. Yeah. How
do you say his last name?
That's that you're talking to me.
I'm the worst at as to how do you,
how do you think it's it?
Tele k one,
two Carew tuck heroin
to Carol. Yeah. You don't want
this. And then he posted that. Yup.
It's awful, right? No, it's just a
tool moods. Awful. Well, it's just me.
Maybe it wasn't him sparring. I don't
know who was getting k. I would like that.
But that should be an example of just
what not to do. A hundred or are you,
what does the [inaudible] shoot box
back in fucking 97 what are you doing?
Does it show the translation?
No. Who Cares? Either way.
Either way. I don't post it.
That's how it used to be. That's how guys
spar got back in the day. Like for sure.
Educate your side. I know this why
when you see something like that today,
like hard to see now that's not,
it's not smart.
It's not good for you and
it's not a good way to train.
You're not learning from that. And she got
a break all your toys. So people go, oh,
you fight like that and now
we're good man, we're good.
Or You have to be a guy who can hang
in there in that gym and do that,
but all of you are going to take
unnecessary damage. Can you do it? Yeah,
you can do it. That's how we used to do
it. Everyone has to do the can do it,
but is it smart to do it? Definitely not.
No. That's not the right way to do it.
Especially at his level. We know you're
tough, man. You'll need to knock guys out.
Finding the K one. What
are you doing? Yeah.
Did you watch all the glorious past
weekend? I'm not huge into glory jugs.
I watch all comments. Are you? I know.
I know. You don't like kickboxing.
It's all right to me. I do.
I enjoy it. I appreciate the
art, stuff like that, but I,
I was, I was really into k one
and when it was in its prime,
but with glow I can't,
it's hard for me getting the glory and
there's some amazing guys in there.
I'm just, I only have so much time on my
hands were goalies. Not that's shorty.
Yeah. I Dunno. To me, I like
it better than boxing to me.
I dare you. I'm sorry. I do.
It's like, I don't even know. I'm being
honest. I appreciate it. We'll get glory.
Fight to me is more interesting
than a real good boxing match.
Crazy like kicks crazy like knees.
I like Moyie Thai even more.
More than boxing. Yup.
A good box. A match.
If you rather watch that than Canelo
triple g you got your God. Wow.
That's an exceptional. What's a lifetime
match? You know that wild Ortiz fight,
man, one of the best I've ever
seen. But like say if it was like
bull cow versus San Chai. Yeah. I would
be just as excited about it. Yeah,
that's fair. You know what I mean? Like
those two levels. Yeah. That level.
That is not so extreme. That's
crazy fight. Yeah. You'd
want to see what happens.
Yeah. I don't know. I just, again, I can
appreciate it when there's a good fight.
I'm down by,
I don't,
I'm not going to shut down my knight in
order pizza and watch a glory. I will.
I will for sure. But yeah, I don't
miss it, which is weird. Which I,
I don't miss any MMA.
UFC bellatore I don't miss any boxing.
There's Sally shut everything down.
Did you get excited about the Kovalev
fight or was it just like, Nah,
I get excited about it. Anytime.
Yeah. Super excited about it.
Like this past weekend I was so,
I was just so happy because I knew I had,
I had fricking showtime boxing
on with wilder for short tees,
which is a great fight.
And then you also had UFC two 22 so when
you can in that ended before the event
events. I get to see all of it. That makes
my weekend, man. Did you see that dude?
Uh, Alexander Hernandez
starch, but Neil Darr, huge.
Did he effort dare you?
She's hitting a rough patch.
How about your boy Hector [inaudible]
x one bar. That wasn't good.
Where are you at on that cheap
shot? Cheap shot you think? Yeah.
I think it was a natural actress
Combo you can get away with. I agree.
The second punch, he knows the bell's
already rung. The first one I said, right,
you're, you're in motion. But that's
that second one that knocked them out.
That's where I got to draw the line.
Yeah, it's healthy. It's bad die.
But it's also a natural
counter to kick like that,
to throw that straight right with
the left hook. So maybe there's that,
but you can't have the fight carry on.
We definitely naturally fired back,
but he knew in his head that the bell
had rung and he fired back anyway.
I mean that's what it, that's what
happened. Why did he do it? I don't know,
but here's the thing. We can't
speculate. We don't know. No one knows.
It was on purpose.
While you know as the bell rings
and rules the rules real clear,
the bell rings to do, throws a punch
and then another punch after the bell,
a hundred percent foul. There's no gray
area like that. They're going to appeal.
That to me is crazy and act two was
saying something like the guy was talking.
He was fine. Just keep saying
what happened? Where am I? Yeah,
that's what's the CB dollar? He said,
yeah, he said it over. I kept saying that.
He was saying I was letting everybody
know because he was saying it over and
over again and we all know what that is.
We've all seen that when a guy gets
knocked out and just keep saying what
happened, what's a nightmare?
It happens so often. Yes.
That is what always happens when
people get KOD suit. They go, Oh shit,
what happened?
You don't remember it.
And you tell them and then five minutes
later what happened and then you tell
him, why am I here? What happened? Like
they forget over and over again all night.
I got to stay up hectors in a tough spot
because he's lost five in a row now.
So I don't, I'm not sure what
they're gonna do with him. Well,
I mean I would imagine if CB wants to
do a rematch, they would do a rematch.
Cause is,
there'd be some interest in that fight
because either one of those guys is not
generating a ton of interest. Hector's
lost a lot of fights, a lot of fights.
These last two, he got knocked out by Mark
Hart. Remember that? Yeah, that was bad.
That was bad.
And that was,
it seemed to me like one of those fights
where he thought Mark Hart was done,
you know, lasting to go donate retired.
Yeah. Officially she retired. Yeah.
I'm glad.
I'm glad I'm retired.
But there's a thing that happens
to fighters where you know,
there's can't take a shot anymore.
They just been doing it too long.
It's just a fact.
And so guys go after him,
but the last thing to go with
a guy like Nate is power. Yeah.
He knocks out CB after CB. Um, you know,
can you see became back and who did he be?
I thought CV one,
two in a row and then they got Hector
or did he lose it? One in decision,
but I'm pretty sure after mate
he won one. Well, you know,
he got fucked up in an elevator accident.
He's in a lawsuit with the UFC over it.
Yeah. He's like permanently fucked
up. Is that that one happened? Yeah,
he was on an elevator and
it just dropped to elevate.
It just dropped and slammed onto the
bottom. I'm sorry. How's at the UCS Brown?
It's, I don't think he's in a lawsuit
with the z not am I crazy is a lawsuit.
I think with the hotel, I thought
it was the UFC. Maybe I'm wrong.
It doesn't make sense if the elevator
and then I have misinformation because it
wouldn't make sense come after the UFC.
If it was a whole hotel and you
didn't know that it was the,
the elevator accident. I knew
it was the elevator. So yeah,
it doesn't make sense that
they'd come after the year.
I only come after you have sex.
What I heard,
but it apparently there was quite a
few people in that elevator and when he
dropped,
a lot of them got fucked up like more
than three or four people in the elevator.
But he got fucked up bad. Was
it a Steve Wynn? I don't know.
I don't know who owned it. I don't
know where it was. Do not remember.
That's such a shame for that though.
Yeah,
but he did go and fight again, so they
would probably be arguing like, hey,
you're still professional because what?
I was getting sick because he's in that
law suit. Then you fight this weekend,
the courtrooms can be like, hold up,
you're saying your packs and issue,
they fought Hector lumbar you're
talking about, that's true, right.
The best argument would be did not fight
until the lawsuits settled and wait,
shoot some stem cells in there. Down
in Panama. Yeah. So listening tiny.
See you ever standing on the headphones?
Wyndham hotel in Cleveland dumps.
Don't stay at window or do so they'll
a sue the shit out of those people.
We'll see what happens.
But yeah,
the p the o elevator apparently was
getting funky on people before and uh,
people were still riding it don't,
don't more people die in elevators.
Cause when they, they, they're
like talking to her friend.
They assume the elevators here and
then walking. The elevator's not,
then they go down.
More people die like that.
Then really even imagine yet why the word
doesn't come our open because the door,
cause it thinks you know something's
wrong and they're like, yeah,
and they fall to their death.
It's a bad one.
So always look at the elevators there.
That's fucked up. Way to end it.
Shitty deal.
You don't want to go out like that.
No.
I heard a story about a dude who got
trapped in an elevator in the elevator,
went up and he was trapped
in the door in the elevator,
went up and just shared them
in half. Oh yeah. I saw that.
And final destination to maybe that's
what it was. And I made it up now.
I'm pretty sure it was real.
That'd be a terrible way to go.
It's like that actor who was in Star
Trek and he was in Alpha Dog. He was,
he lived right up here, man in Hollywood,
Hollywood hills. He lives on, uh,
on an incline and it was
getting out of his jeep to,
to close the garage door
and he didn't put the,
the jeep and park and it rolled up,
killed him, rolled over and killed him.
Trapped against the garage door.
Young actor to phenomenal actor.
Ah, fuck. Wow.
Baxter on the elevator, one leg in the
elevator, one late in the second floor.
He was helping the occupants get off
the elevator when all of a sudden shot
upwards beheading him. That's it.
His body fell into the second floor.
Lobbies had fall onto the
floor of the elevator,
his head and the two remaining pastures
in the elevator shot up to the ninth
floor and one of the passenger described
the scene. I can't get out of my mind.
The head was there, the
bar, but the body wasn't.
He still had the Walkman
earphones on his head. Holy Shit.
There've been many problems with the
elevator and the service repairman was at
the building that day to work on it.
The elevator had been inspected November
1st, 1994 and passed the inspection.
The blue dog. Shit. That's a way to go,
baby. Not Good, painless though guests,
but you will be awake
for a couple seconds.
You know they say once you get chicken,
right.
That doesn't make sense to
me though because how come
you not awake when you get
choked out?
Right?
Well, because when you, when
you get decapitated, right,
everything's still finding some of the
energy still up there firing so you can
see,
maybe I heard about the chicken.
It didn't have any head live for 18
months without a noggin. After farming,
a failed attempt at slaughter axed off
the head of missed the juggler vain.
We really, we really don't know,
right? When people lose their heads,
shake hands are fucking dinosaurs,
man. The Shit. I've said that many,
many too many times, but that kind
of shit is what you need to see.
Just realize this is not,
that's not person.
Although a pterodactyl is not a
dinosaur. It's so strange to me. I know.
I think Tara doctors might've
had feathers. They don't know.
They're thinking now that a
lot of dinosaurs had feathers,
but when you think about
what a terra data is,
we always assume it had like bat wings,
but now that they think that dinosaurs
had feathers, I wonder if they giant bird.
Yeah.
I wonder if they've decided to look into
that and look it at as a possibility.
You ever see or see that giant picture
that it's the t rex covered in feathers?
Yeah. That shit out of my face
didn't look like that bitch.
They might've covered raptors covering.
They had feathers. They've looked
pretty dope too, man. You seen the PA?
Have you seen the pictures dating that
bullshit? T-Rex covered in feathers. Yeah,
that one's furry. It was cute. Be
Willing elements. Cool. Yeah. See, um,
that one we, we showed it
before it's out here, Bozeman,
Bozeman Science Museum
or some shit in Bozeman,
Montana. Pretty cool
place. And they have, uh,
a replica of what they think are wrapped
or could have looked like if it was
covered in feathers because they think
it's very possible that that's what those
things looked like. Remember Jamie? There
was, it was on the floor. There was a,
an actual model.
We pulled up the image before.
I mean if you go to images and
some science shit for the feathers,
but if that's what they think because um,
they found some that have feathers,
they know that they've got some fossils
that have like very clear indentations
where feathers must've been,
well then everything I grew up
on with dinosaurs is wrong. Well,
they think that's true anyway.
They used to think the t
rex was a Predator and now
they think it's a scavenger.
I think this is vegetarian. No, they
think he just waddled around just crow.
Like that's why the teeth are so big,
crushed dead animals that are just
laying around. That's it right there.
That's what I think
that thing looked like,
which is kind of even more nightmarish,
more freaky big life feathered fucking
lizard that runs and gutsy with its
claws.
My brains trying to analyze it.
It doesn't really work well
cause how we know dinosaurs,
you know they have an eagle man. I mean
eagle is a lot like a fucking dinosaur.
It just, it has a hatchet for a head
instead of instead of teeth. Yeah,
but you look at an ostrich,
you look at their legs and shit.
You can see dinosaur in it.
Hundred percent feet. Yeah.
But nobody has teeth like that.
There's not a single bird that
has like leopard seal type teeth.
You know God leopard seal
on underappreciate. Angela
things mean as fuck.
One of the coolest animals of all time.
We were on the scooters and went down.
There's all these leopard seals.
There's some people taking pictures
of some agent. Dude walked up,
got nose to nose with this thing.
I told my brother you could get your
camera out cause that thing is a full rip
his face off and this could be awesome.
God,
they're fucking killers, man. Third
Leopard. You know what I'm saying?
Like the Leopard for for a reason.
But you know,
I didn't even know they were a real
thing until I watched that march of the
penguins movie and went, what?
You know they're real. I didn't,
I didn't know what a fucking re leopard
seal was. I'd never heard of it.
Other gangster and they haven't Skinner
cause since a kid I was in Mexico and
there's one going up in the
water, I thought, oh cute look,
it's like the ones I see on cartoons and
my dad's friend who was a navy was like,
do not go in the water. Those things
are mean as fuck. I was like, really?
He's like, yes, they're out there
fucking killing shit right now. Yeah,
they've eaten people before. There's
one of them, either poor penguin,
a scientist,
actually a female scientist
in a rare attack got killed,
I want to say about 10 years
ago. It was, things are gangster.
They were pretty stunned because they
have giant mounds and huge teeth will look
like with his mouth closed there.
Look so fucking cute. Like, hey buddy.
That's what the Asian dudes doing.
Nose to nose with the Spaghetti.
I buddy now get me a picture of his teeth
like right above with his mouth open.
Go large on that. That's not even a good
one. I think it looks like a tremor. Yeah,
right there. Oh, Jesus Christ. It's like
tremors. Look at that man. I mean that is,
that doesn't look like a real thing.
That looks like a fake animal.
It looks like the movie
Trevor gets shitty. CGI and
tremor. That's Alexa. Yeah,
there was earthquakes cause it has worms.
Look at underground.
Just think the movie's awesome.
Shout out to Kevin Bacon.
I was thinking this about the Oscars.
Like go to that one in the lower left.
Look at these fucking teeth. He looks
right to me. I'll kick your teeth, bro.
Sheer fish dock. He's like, I'd be
really happy to eat your ass hole 100%.
Want to take a bite out of your Dick.
Ever said, man, they're fucking killers.
We're going to say about
the Oscars though. Oh, I was
thinking in the killers. No,
I was thinking like,
when are we no one,
it's no one can possibly see all
the movies because we keep
adding to the library every week.
No movies come out,
they don't take movies away.
You have to hit a certain period where
they're going to preview that movie.
So you're up for the awards.
And that's not what I mean.
I don't care about the Oscars.
I don't care what the awards were saying.
The number of movies that we produce
as the human race is fucking crazy.
And it's never ending.
Like every year they put out
more and movies don't go away.
So they just, the database, just stacking
and stacking and stacking up the fall.
And it's only been happening for
a hundred years. Yeah, I mean,
and that was silent in the beginning.
Right?
So there's been a hundred years of these
movies just stacking up and all the
premises. Like if you think
about premises, like the pro,
the robots get smart and they
want to kill the people. Okay. Oh,
the monkeys get smart and they
want to kill the people. Okay.
Like there's all these premises
that just go, oh, there's worms.
They live on the ground that caused
earthquakes. I get great movie.
Like this is so many of these.
Amen. Immediately. So many like,
like it's must be so hard to come up
with an original premise for a movie.
There's so many fucking movies like you
think it's hard to come up with a new
joke or a new premise for a joke. Well,
the white think movies. What do you think?
You get like a re creation of
Jumanji rocky and Predator.
Like they're running out of ideas.
How many buddy buddy movies can we see?
Can we put the Rock Kevin Hart's?
I'll be God damn movies.
It was just the regurgitation of all
the same shit we've already seen. Yeah.
Yeah. It's, there's so many movies
get, there's not that many paid actors.
Is there like it's a struggle city
less than 1% make it living, acting,
but there's a juggle in movies.
Is it less than 1% less less
than 1% make a living really?
Can Movies of all actors?
Yes. Wow, that's crazy.
Like a quality living of all the actors.
Less than 1% that's pretty crazy.
Crazy thick.
La Comics make a legit living.
Can you make comics are the difference
being that for a comic it's more up to
them. Correct. Some more up to them to go.
And you're a good piece of proof for that.
Obviously you have the boost of being
famous from the UFC and then being famous
from your podcast.
Those two,
two things helped you as a
boost but also the hustling.
And that's the thing that like an actor
can hustle, but you have to be hired.
They gotta be hired to do something
and there's a million moving pieces.
1 million you gotta track. Well,
your test. Well people have to like,
you gotta be right for the Royal.
You could just go up on a showcase night
and do like 15 minutes and kill and
you're in the money,
you know,
acting to mother fucker hard Gig
to get good at too, you know,
acting. Yeah. I think
like God to get good at,
like Daniel Day Lewis style was watching.
There will be blood the other day and I
was just thinking like this guy like the
butcher hooding out so many.
Yeah. Ooh, in New York.
What does that gangs in the area, but I
forgot how good there will be. Blood was,
um, I watched it the other day
in a hotel and uh, I was uh,
near where it happened because I was
doing gigs in Fresno and Bakersfield and
uh, I didn't know that, but
that to hatch a p mountains,
that's where there will
be bloods all about.
That's where they were drilling for oil.
That's right over there. Amazing movie,
Dude. I think it's funny sometimes
fighters, whoever, athletes go home,
I'm going to go to Hollywood,
get into act. I'm like, Ma,
you need to sit in on a class where you,
you need to watch someone do like a
dramatic role and see if it's for you.
I mean, you're talking about
it's a legit craftsmen.
Some people are just good at this.
There's a thing that they're
doing where you're, you are,
you're compelled by their words peddled
by where they're doing and it's not easy
to gift, you know? It's not
easy to achieve that spot.
Not a lot of guys do it. No,
it's a true art that that's why it's so
tough to get cast in those roles in TV
and movies. There's a reason
why it's so. We've got amped up.
I've been watching that Viking show.
You watch that Viking show that's on
history, right? All in baby. Yeah.
You get on apple. I got on
iTunes. It's fucking good, man.
It's good show and it keeps getting
better and they're really good actors.
I'm on season two right
now. I need some shows, man.
I ran out while you seen punisher on
Netflix. I have not changed your life.
It's that good. It's, you would love it.
It's a lot of shoot 'em ups Helia
like legit. I just don't like action.
That doesn't do anything for them. I like
a good story. Yeah. Punisher stope rent.
What went through El Chapo
went through narcos. Dual work.
You've never seen the wire. Have you
ever seen the wire seeing the wire?
I get like season five, that's all there
is. I just did it. Release it in HD,
so if you haven't seen it you could
watch it. Some people say grace,
it's probably the best series ever.
Ever. Yeah. That's a strong statement.
Easier for you to say because
I haven't seen it. You fuck.
That's true. It is true.
That is. It is right. Some
people are making number one
that and soprano's. Right.
I've seen as a problem number one.
Well that's a problem. Her son,
I saw one episode of the wire. Well
I've seen half an episode of Sopranos.
Sopranos was the show that got me into
binge watching but not binge because you
know,
watched every Sunday whenever it was on
or whatever it and HBO night with your
girl. It was a big, it was a big deal to
sit and watch the sopranos. I was like,
boy, you would go to the fucking
time I was with game of Thrones.
It's Brian here.
Yeah.
He has some poor electric
car that he half charges.
How often you think Brian fully charged?
Is that car just in the shop?
Cause he's like ran into a wall or some
shit. He cheats. His car is like shit.
And then he goes, dude, you think I
should get a Porsche like you and Rogan?
Like no, absolutely not. Absolutely
not. That's not the guy for you.
He's hitting full on midlife crisis.
Let's, let's encourage it. No,
I want them to get a yellow
viper like in braces.
Like I want to be that guy in
a Shit Tan and way. Ooh, Viper.
Now he doesn't know how to
drive enough for a viper but he,
he should drive something that has some
balls. Yeah, Tesla's bummed me out.
I like the message.
That's just not the car for me.
Does that make any noise problem?
The fact that it doesn't make any noise.
Don't know why.
I'm just too used to noise too.
I know we sound like
two cavemen right now,
but that doesn't have that v
eight or that fee. 10 noise,
the fees six and let's
say bowl that exhaust,
there's nothing and I, you know
what, it's pissing me off lately.
Car Manufacturers have been adding
noise to their cars, like the Maserati.
They put it in this in the
speakers. What? Yes. In what cars?
Bmw m three m four does it.
They put in the speakers sound.
They pumped sound through the speakers.
That's a bitch. As the engine goes up,
it comes. Some of it's coming
in through the speakers.
It's like pan abroad as a girl.
It's apparently some guys have
figured out a way how to cut that out.
I think what you do turbocharge cars,
turbocharged car.
Can I say that five times turbo car,
turbo charged cars.
When you have forced induction,
forced hot air induction,
it makes the car a much quieter.
Doesn't sound nearly as like throaty and
rumbly like my gt three, you know raw.
That thing sounds because it's
naturally aspirated and you also get
instantaneous feedback from the,
from the throttle response, the GTA.
That's what you want.
When you get into turbo
chargers is all about turbo lag,
which is why they have twin turbos.
They have one turbo on the low end,
one turbo on the high end.
But even at the very best
implementations of turbo chargers,
there's still a perceptible lag.
Slight lag.
Slightly getting better and better though
much about Porsche's. Ridiculous. Yeah,
yeah, yeah. Um, they get,
they're definitely better
than they used to be. Dude.
How the fuck even up in cars? Uh,
comedians in cars getting coffee.
Oh I dunno not, no, I did Jay Leno show.
I've done enough car things.
That's true.
But let's take the new Porsche and get
on there so I can't believe you're from
Newport. Literally. I was like, um, I,
I want, I hit you about the podcast.
I'm just here to see the car and he didn't
bring it has an oil leak. I know. Yeah.
Well you buy, it's not
new. It's 1991, 1991,
nine six four something.
I wanted to uh,
fuck around with one of those older cars.
I like those. Love it. They're small.
They're real small.
That's one of the weird things
about it when you're around it,
like those things at tiny a
driver's car. Yeah. I love it.
Cause you're not going to see it.
No one has it at the,
it's custom to you to Ben as ride.
There's more of them now
than they have been before.
People getting a little older cars.
Thanks to your boy Magnus Walker.
Chris Harris had something funny to me.
He said,
why is it the four years ago I didn't
give a shit about nine six force now I
think that the best looking cars ever,
there's the,
it goes to Porsche goes through these
phases where this one's cool. Yes.
So the 68 to 78 73 it's
just these weird phases.
Well those long hood cars are kind
of always the best looking ones.
That 19 like 67 to like 70 early seventies
like 72 73 you know they had that
long hood doesn't ones that magnus
is really into. He's done on a fruit.
A few of those. We redid them. He made
them cool too. Yeah. Oh yeah. For sure.
Well his style like that,
that's another level more raw than
when I'm dealing with magnus. Yeah.
Because his style of, well
he has a nine, six, four,
two but a lot of what
his older cars where,
where those 1969 1970 ones and those,
he
would redo those and those cars don't wait
dawg. Shit, they wait like 2000 pounds.
Not like the Porsche purest think like
they're not really into the singers or
the Magnus Walker.
You know what I'm saying?
I think your car's in the middle of
that, I think. Yeah, it's not modified.
It's not like a singer,
which is completely different and
saying he's got a carbon fiber body.
I actually think uh,
singers that they might be getting,
there's a law supports took a lawsuit
out of them because they're selling the
Porsches,
but they're taking the Porsche logo off,
put a singer one on now she's in washes
suing them. They have an issue with it.
Yeah.
That's interesting.
I thought they liked it because it was
just like bringing back interest in.
I think they lot worship before
you started making it the singer.
You know what I'm saying? Yeah. Because
what he's doing is taking a nine,
six four which is that same
year that I'm talking about,
and then he puts all this other stuff
on it and be set up the suspension and
beefs up the engine like impossible
to get to their show sick.
Well now he has a new one that's
starts at one point $5 million.
Is that it? Jesus Christ.
Fuck we did. I was seeing it.
There's a limited number of
them they're going to make.
It has a 500 horsepower
naturally aspirated engine.
It's got giant fender flares.
They just see if you could find
it saying [inaudible] you're in.
Wait till you take a look at this thing.
Sometimes that like when you send me
pictures of Kaiser getting made some dumb.
I see. It makes me mad. They're
so sick. It makes you mad.
Like just not enough cars in the world
for me. Yeah. What is it about cars?
I know cars and girls they'd like,
you'll see it.
You're like God damn right.
It just speaks to DNA and it's,
it's uh, it's not all men.
Callan, Callan to come in here.
You could show them that
cause see the dressing room.
I mean I've had guys walking around the
gym see him cause he's [inaudible] he
hits that punching thing you have,
cause you gotta break it.
He's got karate power or would go, you
know what I would but my wrist. Yeah.
Maybe it was that. But this, I
mean some men don't get into it,
but it's so universal with men.
It's just,
it's so normal that men like really get
into cars. Why is that? I don't know.
I don't know what it is. A battle,
especially V eights, right.
I'm not the type of guy where I'll see
a car and my brother's supercar to go
that thing you're, you're quite
stressed out on the track. I'm like,
I don't give a shit about the track man.
There's guys who are like those track
guys and I'm just like a road guy.
Fun Driving car fast enough.
But looks great.
All about looks and performance tracking.
A lot of people are track guys.
We should go to the track. The
Porsche. Yeah, we go there.
We have to take their cars though.
Fuck up their tires. Yeah, that's true.
Not Yours. That's true. He can get
gt three, gt two, eh. All right,
let's do it. Let's do that. That's
the, that's the second. Come on son.
That does make a dick thing up.
Porsche nine six,
four dls and this thing is insight.
A better looking car than that though.
You know what I'm saying? Well I'm a, I'm
going to be honest. Those Fukes wheels,
I always felt like they're not
good enough for that body style.
I like the look how the wheel wells in
that. I always felt like their classic,
those folks are quite late and they have
a center locking hubs to see that look
in the fuck that body on that thing.
They'll fee Ooh and the tail on the back.
That's the only reason I bought my car
cause the ducktail look at the back end.
All my God, that might be one of the
best looking cars ever, ever, ever.
Was the interior like done that to me.
Oh it's phenomenal. It's orange. It's,
you're going to be orange.
I said look at the center locks man.
And like people will say, all be
spoke the interior. Look at that.
Jesus Christ. How much is it? 1.6 million.
It makes me want to risk it
all. Yeah, right. Just sign
up for it. If I was Connor,
I do one than Burger King commercials
and buy one of these two different,
were you? I'd get when these
fucking things. It's not my style.
That's a little too little too little
clicks on them. We'll take cars. Lipstick.
Orange saw me do it.
I gotta a silver Bronco already.
I got that silver corvette that I have.
That's about as, that's your style though.
Look at my Dick.
As you can get that pulled that,
I mean you gotta you gotta you gotta
fricking, you know that that night.
Red fucking Porsche classic
red. Yeah, it's the guards.
Red Guards red. Yeah. Great call
is good. You'll see it soon.
What's the matter? He's trying
to do dips, but he's not quite,
we're watching Cowan workout on the
security camera. Why does he come in here?
Cause he's Cowen. Let's wrap this
up. We'll go get them. All right. Um,
what's getting Cami dates coming up? Yes,
I'm in Auc Star levity live next week.
And then I grade classes all
march, Oxnard, levity live
next week. Friday, Saturday,
Friday, Saturday be March
16th, 17th levity live Oxnard.
And then the following week I'm in
Florida. Tampa, the 22nd Palm Beach,
23rd and 24th or land on the 25th.
Brendan schaub.com a t five k.com.
T fat.
Can they check out below the belt first
episodes out that's right at below the
belt. My, my showtime show drops. So
showtime print shop blew the fuck.
What's up, bro? We'll be
back with Brian Cowen.